à à
anh alo cho các bạn
mình
mình đến nợ chưa ăn gì cả thì mình xin
phép để cũng tranh thủ đầu tiên thì cho
các bạn xem video này ở một cái hài thôi
nhưng mà cũng rút ra được một vài Thư
đấy các bạn cứ ngồi xem mà mình chính
chủ người ăn trong vòng 8 phút nhé à
à à
Xin chào bạn nghe thì mình ạ Alo ạ
a a
genoa Francis I
Ừ
[âm nhạc]
Tôi muốn nghe à
Anh
[âm nhạc]
ăn chưa Lộ biết rồi
bố tôi ngồi ấy tôi đâu mà để ốm lâu chưa
xanh cỏ
có gì đây này chỉ
là người đi không ạ
[âm nhạc]
không
cho xem thì thôi
Chung Vợ
ăn được chơi xe khác để tao
[âm nhạc]
[Tiếng cười]
không qua trường rồi thì khóc à
[âm nhạc]
[Tiếng cười]
anh kia nô Excellent
[âm nhạc]
đi đề này đã được
haha à
[âm nhạc]
t-ara's
ăn thịt lợn
[Tiếng cười]
lạ
ta phải được à
[âm nhạc]
[Tiếng cười]
a
Excellent đ
[âm nhạc]
[Tiếng cười]
ừ ừ
[âm nhạc]
ở
Arsenal blđ Arsenal
[âm nhạc]
[Tiếng cười]
condor ừ
ừ ừ
[âm nhạc]
chi
[Tiếng cười]
tiết hơn
[âm nhạc]
một cái
mô hội giờ mày
có thấy ra sợi
[âm nhạc]
nhưng khi ngươi thật à à
Quên à
Anh
nghĩ đi rồi ơi cho chúng ta
béo sẽ lớn à
anh alo ờ
từ video vừa rồi các bạn đúc kết lại ra
điều gì ông đã
à à
ở ngoài việc là mình nên về sau nên làm
phục vụ quán ba ra à
à à
em đừng đùa với phụ nữ
á hậu quả là nhọn
cách làm YouTube không sợ bay kênh 2
Anh ở hôm trước và mình mình thấy là ra
video đấy đang ở nhiều nơi nơi mình giảm
đang ấy
không nên gây thù với phụ nữ
khi người phụ nữ thì hành động dứt khoát
không thì chạy đi Ok
thế là quá sai rồi Nãy giờ mấy ông không
ai biết được cái kết sau câu chuyện đấy
thôi Ngoài việc là này có thực sự thì nó
cái Hải ra nếu thực sự ngoài đời mình
như thế
300 cái Chính Chính vì cái ông chủ kia
đẹp trai là một yếu tố thôi
Ừ nếu mấy ông xe mở đầu video ở Đúng là
thấy một ông đẹp trai xong rồi tán tỉnh
với một cô cũng xinh gái một cách tương
đương để họ một cái xứng đáng thì thấy
hai người có vẻ hợp đôi nhau ngay từ lúc
đầu rồi Đương nhiên à và Đúng là cô kia
về ăn ý với anh đấy anh lại cũng theo ý
luôn Cô ấy chỉ cần vén tóc thôi rồi có
nhờ anh ấy hiểu là cô ấy đồng ý rồi
chồng ngoại anh gửi qua luôn đi
là phụ nữ ướt lặng không thích làm gì
cũng quê à Cũng đúng nhưng mà thật là
cũng sai Tôi bảo ở Nếu được Sợ là nếu
giờ sự trong hoàn cảnh đấy mà
mà kiểu
bị thế xong đúng không ạ
Cái đoạn cuối ra trước mình cái đoạn
cuối
mấy ông để ý kĩ là ngay từ lúc đầu cô
gái ấy đã cười rồi cô gái lúc đầu bọn họ
lại bị ngu Bạc Hà Nhung ạ Đấy xong rồi
từ chối cô đấy là một con người kiểu vừa
quyết đoán và vừa có tính cách hơi hơi
hơi kiểu gọi anh à không Hiền không Hiền
lắm đấy gọi từ từ không hiền đấy nhưng
mà với những người như thế Thực ra là
đây là cách tán gái đấy Đó là mấy ông
anh không không hẳn đã trêu đùa kiểu như
thế nhưng mà mấy ông sẽ kiểu
đôi khi là mấy ông sẽ phải chuyển hướng
Giang không phải làm thân thì chúng ta
sẽ đến 5 kẻ địch cũng được à
Ừ nhưng mà chúng nhưng mà không nên quá
đà quá và
luôn chấp nhận mình đấy thức chính vì
ông ấy không đẹp trai ông ấy cái mặt
kiểu trông được cũng cũng kiểu như nhờ
tấu hài khi bị mấy cái trò lỗ kia thì
được ăn cái phi cươi
nó cười ông là thời gian ghi điểm rất
mạnh rồi và khi mà ông chấp nhận chịu
thua chứ OK thì ăn Điệp thực sự như thế
Ừ nếu để ý kĩ quả đấy nếu mà giờ sửa là
trong trường hợp thật ngoài đời hợp và
đấy anh kia rủ đi uống cà phê sau đó nữa
Ừ thì chắc chắn sẽ rủ nữa A và cho sẵn
sẽ cậu thoải mái lúc đấy bạn kia hoàn
toàn cây mỡ
mấy ông thực ra không hề biết được là
cái
Ừ cái
khoảng cách giữa bạn bạn bạn bình thường
so với người yêu đối với con gái ra
khoảng cách rất xa thế là mục khi ông
rửa fanzone đấy ông sang thì yêu rất khó
nhưng khoảng cách giữa kẻ địch với người
yêu đối với con gái nhá Nó khoảng cách
rất gần
Vì thế nên là hồi bể mấy ông tôi khi tư
tưởng và cách để đưa ngày cái chùy mình
ấy nó còn chưa tròn kiểu trêu nó kiểu
thì hay trêu trêu nó rất thấy thích bạn
nào ý trêu bạn đấy ông ạ trêu trêu không
những ở cậu nói kiểu châm chọc kêu mà
đôi khi còn gây sự chú ý bằng cách là
được Giật Tóc hay cái gì đó gây sự chú ý
Ông ngoại ấy là cái bản năng nổi nhưng
mà đang nói là yếu tố mà con gái sẽ dễ
cổ loại dễ có cảm tình với người mà mình
ghét hơn đấy trong cho người con trai
nhé Còn con cái ghét con gái thì nó chưa
nó khác con gái hết con gái thì không
bao giờ đội trời chung luôn đấy dùng
khác
chứ không phải xin lỗi nữa mà vừa rồi là
đứa con trai còn
chịu thua trước và còn nhường cái thứ
thứ
bản năng bản năng của
bản năng khác giới thì luôn cố kiểu gây
sự chú ý với khác giới kia thôi bằng mọi
cách đúng ạ Đấy ông có thể là một bé thì
ông chẳng biết gì cả thì ông sẽ làm thế
chỉ có thể là gặp ai Ông cũng thể trêu
chọc nhưng mà chất thật muốn gặp người
ấy ông sẽ phải hành động một kiểu khác à
em lấy nhầm đại khái à Nó vẫn à
Ừ nó nó vẫn đúng bọn gái nó luôn luôn
nhớ về người mình yêu người mình ghét
rất mạnh Nếu là mấy ông chuyển từ người
ông Tư kệ địch Đông phát bảo là thực ra
từ trước này anh trêu hai anh cố tình
làm thế gây sự chú ý em cái
mấy ông xem phim mới Ông thấy rõ điều
đấy rồi mà nó là thực tế luôn tâm lý học
nó lễ
tâm lý học hỏi noi
thế thế nên là mấy ông Cư cơ thưởng mà
xem mấy ông làm bạn nó còn An Đương
nhiên với tùy từng con gái nhiều con gái
mà kiểu bọn đọc cả sách tâm lý học rồi
ông chơi giờ tao đi học được nhưng mà à
Ừ nhưng mà tôi là tội từng tán gái thì
cười đấy và lần rồi
ừ ừ
Ừ ok và bây giờ mình sẽ tâm sự thêm một
tí về kể Ừ bắt chuyện của con gái hôm
nay on muộn để bây giờ mới đến tâm sự
Ừ thì à
Ẩm Thực ra là khi mà khi bắt được con
gái Mấy ông không nên tự tạo rào cản cho
mình là một con người lạ một con người
kiểu dạng là tao xác định tán mai này
cần nhắn tin cho Nhắn tin lần đầu tiên
nhắn tin em đấy Trưởng Chào em Anh có
thể làm quen được không Nó cậu nó sẽ
nghĩ đủ thứ trong đầu thực ra là thì ông
tốt ở Hôm nay có học anh nhá Có học làm
nốt trả lời nói của mẹ mình sẽ mình sẽ
vào bài học ở chỗ hôm nay tâm sự là
nhiều hơn có mai sẽ buổi giao lưu cũng
là nhiều hơn hôm nay cuối năm rồi mà cái
đoạn gửi mail tím Tôi dậy ôm ấy ông cùng
nấm 15 phút bởi vì cái đoạn đấy có cốt
để có trên mạng về thôi Mình chỉ hướng
dẫn các bạn cách làm thôi à em
hãy nói chung là về cái việc mà lần được
tin nhắn tin con gái thứ nhất là phải
thể hiện nó con đứa này biết sự tồn tại
của ông đã Thường mấy ông có thể
like hoặc bình luận gì gì đó kết bạn
trên Facebook like bình luận khoảng một
khoảng thời gian đã Trước khi nhắn tin
chứ không phải nhắn tin đúng phát biểu
người kết bạn gái của em đấy chấp nhận
các bạn mình rồi sẽ chắn là em đã yêu
mình
hay là
váy cưới chọn váy nào Cái ngữ vân vân
ông bộ vào con cá nhờ người ta như thế
được nữa ạ Bọn gái nó có cái giá của nó
rất là ngại thế nên là mấy ông không
chơi được Kiểu như thế
Vì thế nên là mấy ông không đi chơi được
kiểu người Bồ Đào như thế mấy ông từ từ
không ạ Từ từ ở đây nhưng mà Từ từ ở đây
tôi chơi cách này cơ đó là mấy ông có
thể giờ ông biết những lần tôi nhận tôi
tán gái một cách thành công mỹ mãn phải
những lời như nào tin nhắn đầu tiên của
tôi không phải là xin chào Hãy cái gì đó
chính là đầu tiên của tôi alo
Đấy xong rồi Ê cái thử thứ
nhưng mà đương nhiên là tôi đã nói ấy
tôi bình luận trước mà mấy bài bạn đấy
và coi nó làm kẹo đường biến thành mình
là một người vô duyên với điều kiện là
mình không nên biến thành mình một người
vô duyên quá Mình nói chuyện với bình
thường thưởng rồi tỏ ra cậu mình cũng
chung sở thích là gần sau đó đi với nhắn
tin kiểu là mình như bạn coi bạn để có
nhiều bạn
Ừ chứ không phải là bạn thân nhưng mà
cũng không phải là bạn không phải là
người lạ người xa lạ Nếu mà tự mình tạo
rào cản là người xa lạ
Ừ thì con gái coi bạn đúng như người xa
lạ thật đấy
con gái
khi tỉa của Saka giác quan rất ngại
Nhưng mà tôi nói thật mà mày ông một
điều đó là lý trí không ngại lắm người
ta chơi cảm tính nhiều hơn thế nên là
rất nhiều đứa con gái Thực sự thì có sẽ
cho dù ông quen đứa nè đấy ba năm rồi
cho một đứa mà mới mới giặt
à mà gây một vài cảm xúc thoáng qua đứa
con gái đấy nó sẽ ấn tượng hơn cả ông 35
ngân hàng ra là
như ông bảo là em tán bạn đấy 3450 đổ có
tự nhiên có một hàng bạn mới quen hai
ngày vào yêu nó Tại sao lại như thế bởi
vì con gái chơi theo kiểu tình cảm hơn
lý trí ở cái đoạn đấy nếu là mấy ông
không phải ngại việc là bạn em này mới
quen bắt chuyện khác Thả này có mấy cái
thằng mà tám bạn để lâu rồi vẫn chưa ra
mình Bây giờ mình mất chuyện không được
với Vân
không tất cả mấy cái ra hết mình mình sẽ
vậy chơi theo kiểu là cứ rất là bình
thường Đừng có tỏ ra mình đang trực trực
kiểu sau em đấy được
mình mình mình cứ nói chuyện
như bạn bình thường thật là con gái rất
thích bạn khác giới mà Thế ông cứ thoải
mái thôi đừng có thoải mái vô to quá là
được Em đừng nói kiểu chữ đến nhảy vào
chủ đề 18 cộng là được mấy ông cứ nói
chuyện như với bạn bè bình thường
vì vậy Nãy giờ mày Ông hỏi nhiều phết là
tự chế độ tranh thủ trả lời mày coi
nhưng đại hai cách bắt chuyện của tôi
như thế nhá cái bắt chuyện của tôi rồi
nóc nhà
này như thế khi mà bạn ấy quen tôi là ở
biết tao qua cho nhóm Dư Tên công ty
nhưng chỉ biết qua thì thôi dẫn đầu tiên
nó nhắn tin bạn đấy tôi nhắn tin vào lúc
2 giờ sáng mà em liên tục rồi để kia bạn
trả lời thôi rồi rồi tôi hỏi đang làm gì
đấy Vợ Vân hỏi như một đứa bạn bình
thường kiểu đi lại như kiểu Quen lâu lắm
rồi Anh xin lỗi tôi vừa văng tục nhưng
mà sáng tôi quen nói chuyện với thằng
sinh viên của tôi là như thế
đấy Em gọi thằng sinh viên đâu em ngồi
đây Đấy sau đó thì
đương nhiên là bạn ấy sẽ bị thoáng ở
nước đầy thằng hai thằng nào không nhớ
bạn lập tức Nhận hàng này mình nhớ thằng
nào xô hội hỏi sao lại ngồi nghĩnh 1 tỷ
tại sao nó lại hỏi mình như thế người
cha không lớn để lâu rồi cứ trả lời sau
cuối cùng thì lần biến hàng khi video
bạn bình thường thôi I
à à
Ừ Ông ngoại bị Block luôn thì thôi dẹp
coi như là bạn đấy không không hợp tính
cách của ông đúng ạ Ông hãy thể hiện đấy
đưa gan đấy là tôi đang chạy để cách
tính cách của tôi là nó như thế thật tôi
cũng từng tán gái tôi tán gái thất bại
rất nhiều không phải không Nhưng mà ẩn
chứa những gặp người mà đúng cũng không
hơn một tí thì sẽ nói chuyện được như
thế à
anh không không biết được tôi Star để
nhà tôi liên tục Ê
trời kia bạn trả lời thôi có cực
về lý thuyết xa thực hành làm ông bây
giờ ông người ta luôn rồi Cái đứa mà
không phải gọi mấy đứa ông thích mà là
bởi
từ ông thử thử gặp một bạn mới đi Sau đó
ông thử làm như thế
à à
Có hôm tôi tôi chia sẻ mấy cái mấy cái
đúng cũng khá cao đấy à
và đương nhiên là mấy ông mà áp dụng các
chiêu đấy với đúng cái bạn mà đã Tân cập
tới chiều ấy rồi chứ
gì nữa là nó không cao hơn à
Thế
hả em Ăn cơm chưa
ăn tối chưa Rồi hỏi có này bất kỳ đứa
con gái nào luôn đấy Thật không hiểu mấy
ông hỏi như thế mới ông tại chọn đúng
rồi Cho tôi hỏi thế với nóc nhà rồi nha
bây giờ nóc nhà còn chán là một Trả Lời
Chưa Nói Hết việc của ông ông việc ở ông
nhắn tin được tại vì ai
à à
anh nói chung là thực ra tùy từng cách
nữa Nhờ bạn kiểu thực ra là mình cũng
bởi với tôi Tôi là con người cũng kiểu
năng nổ Nói nhiều cũng ah
ai cũng tự cho mình là có tí hài hước
kiểu thế mẹ ở trọ không nói chuyện được
với bạn mà được hơi bị ngạt một tí kiểu
dạng mình pha trò bạn đấy Con không hiểu
lại không cười em ạ Từ chung mà còn phải
hợp nữa nhiều cái nữa Nói chung mà Mấy
ông đang quan điểm để được là buổi Cô ấy
là duy nhất mình phải cô Tám bằng được
cô ấy thì sẽ không bao giờ tán được nó
khó bởi vì các bạn nó coi bạn ấy tượng
đài là thần tượng rồi và sợ gây một bất
kỳ một cái Lỗi lầm gì đó thì bạn đấy sẽ
chạy hay gì đó Tại sẽ không nói chuyện
nữa thế là mấy ông làm cứ cẩn thận và
Chính vì cái việc cẩn thận đấy đôi khi
là sẽ tạo tự tạo loài cả nó chính ông và
đứa con gái thì nó bị nhạy cảm' nón cảm
nhận được cái điều không ổn từ ông ông
có điều gì đó mờ ám sẽ giàu nó lên nó sẽ
không không được thoải mái ở bên ông còn
khi mà việc và Ừ ông rất là thoải mái tự
nhiên và ông không sợ không hẳn là sợ bị
tật Nhưng nói chung là ạ Nếu mà giờ sử
mà bạn ấy không phù hợp với ông rồi Ông
cố thế nào nữa thì nó vẫn khó thôi đúng
ạ trước khi là tự nhiên Đúng không thay
đổi lòng con người khác gửi ông tán là
đấy được giống như kiểu thợ sửa ông bây
giờ ông tả không tán được cộng hai năm
nữa ông quay lại ông tán thì có khi lại
được chứ bên trong vòng hai năm đời ông
cứ cố Toán thì bạn đấy cứ cố từ chối
khẳng định đều về luôn Ông Hà hai năm
nữa ông quay lại không tán thì thành
công
anh
em đang nói chuyện với cách kiểu cái tán
gái như thế Nhưng thực sự tôi không quên
tôi không khuyên mấy ông ở biểu hôm
trước tôi còn nói đấy Không phải kiểu
thấy tất cả mọi người xung quanh có
người yêu thì rộng nên có người yêu đúng
không ạ Anh trải qua bao nhiêu mối tình
rồi à có những câu của tôi không biết
nên trả lời không vì câu này thật dễ đi
ăn tốt lắm nên thôi em
ừ ừ
gì hả ông à canh lúc ở bạn đấy chia tay
xong ấy
Ừ không thì tán ngay trong thời gian đấy
tôi thể thôi chưa có tán được cái bạn
nào mới chia tay xong 7 giảm toàn kiểu
bát em anh nhiều nhiều cái tư còn nếu mà
ra xử một tán được trong thời gian đấy
thì nó chẳng qua là nó có một sự kiểu
ông người thay thế tạm thời phải dùng từ
Tạm thời thì thực ra nó cũng ly lớn với
vũ vẫn hoàn toàn thể đá ông phải quay
lại người cũ bị một phát rồi đây này nên
là không mở nữa 8 đứa con gái khi mà nó
chưa dứt điểm được mối tình cũ
Ừ
đúng rồi tán được ngày hôm sau lại quay
lại như cũ
khi con tệ hơn với việc ở ông còn cướp
người yếu của đứa khác nữa chẳng hạn nó
vẫn mù khi móng cướp được bạn đấy hoàn
toàn bạn đấy có vẻ bị cướp với thằng
khác hoa dẫn cho các bạn hãy quay lại
Bởi hàng cũng có
cho nên khóc đi
Em tán để gì đã tôi không dậy mà Ông làm
passport rồi nhé á Ồ không tôi không dậy
mà cái điều đấy
I wake me up giao lưu tâm sự với mấy bạn
kiểu bình luận sôi nổi là đông phết nhỉ
à
anh như thế thì ạ Đợi mình xin phép mình
đọc lại tất cả cô có họ để tâm sự các
bạn để mình trả lời dần nhé á
Ừ để cơ bản là phụ nữ muốn hay không cái
khái niệm phụ nữ muốn hay không hết là
một khái niệm mà chính các bạn đấy còn
không biết giống như các bạn hỏi vụ các
bạn nữ là hôm nay muốn ăn gì
vậy không mở trả được
ở thời sự ở trừ khi các bạn mới thấy
quảng cáo mà thấy mấy bạn bè mới đăng đồ
ăn mình các bạn với hình dung này nghĩa
đôi khi các bạn bật ra một cái gì đó chứ
trong đó có bạn ơi không hạt nằm Đang
nghĩ một cái gì là ở đâu phải thường hay
bị bật ra hơn đây là ông ông như tô hôm
trước tôi từng nói là không mở nên hỏi
con gái à em 15 gì mà mình chỉ cần không
tránh những cái món mà Bạn ấy ghét rồi
cứ đề xuất những cái món mà Mấy ngày nay
không ăn ở Tưởng gì bạn sẽ ăn thôi không
phải lo vấn đề đấy ông sẽ là người cầm
cầm cương gọi là cầm tay lái Ông là
người chủ động bóng đá yêu thích những
thằng con trai chủ động như thế hiểu tôi
như tôi tôi bằng biết nhiều quán ăn ngon
nên anh ạ Tôi chưa Lúc nào dẫn mỗi ngày
dẫn đi vài quán xã hội đổi món đấy Bạn
ấy chẳng ơi kiu chê vào cái hiệu ăn uống
gì cả bạn cứ thế mà ăn thôi thì tương tự
thế
cô con gái Đỗ Thị ở chưa có quyết định
điều và việc ghét hay thích ông đâu và
nọ Thực ra vẫn có thể thay đổi được cái
điều đấy
Ghét hay thích như tôi và nói Thực ra là
vẫn có thể thay đổi được một khi mà nó
chỉ muốn ông là bạn thân đấy rất khó
thay đổi
cho em
âm thanh từ bản thân thì biến thành
người xa lạ luôn kiểu ghét cay ghét tắm
bé người xa lạ luôn chứ không nói chuyện
kiểu biến hàng mình yêu rồi nhé
khi nãy hoài giống như người yêu
nhiều cũ quay lại thằng nhiều cũng khó
à à
anh kể về ngày trước tán cô mình vừa nói
đây mình tán được từ đấy mình cũng chơi
cối thế
anh em có thể tách đoạn anh tâm sự rồi
làm bosket không Ừ mình vẫn làm khi vụ
làm boss cát ở
Ừ nếu mà anh mình sẽ tắt cái đấy mình
gọi không biết cái popkart ở gì cơ
nhưng mà mình sẽ tách một vài cái mẫu
mình chia sẻ tâm sự hoặc cả mình trả lời
mời riêng đó có thể về bên lập trình nữa
để mà làm sót ở trên thích trên chứ top
cả bằng lên Tik Tok dẫn cài Instagram
mình định thế nhưng bây giờ vẫn chưa
thời gian làm đúng đấy
em Inbox để họ để tập làm quen
Ừ nếu mà ông
nếu mà ông tán bạn kiểu tri thức thì bạn
sẽ thích điều đấy con tán bạn đấy Bạn ấy
rốt về môn đấy Bạn ấy sẽ cay không hiểu
tự nhiên động nỗi đau
đi
tán gái toàn đi đường vòng không đi
đường thẳng chẳng được thế là sai rồi
đứng yên ở không nên đi đường thẳng hiểu
đúng và được em muốn ấy ấy không
không không chưa như thế nhưng mà tắm
thì ở không nên giấu giếm một cái gì cả
Cứ thoải mái thôi ông vòng quá với cùng
ông biến hình bạn hơn
em
làm thêm về môn nhập
khi
nhập môn cơ sở dữ liệu
Ừ Ừ
cái này thì mình không chuyên cho sự
mình không chuyên về cả bên đấy em mình
không thể dạy các bạn được mình cũng học
cái đấy mình cũng là tìm hiểu cái đấy
nhiều nhưng mà chỉ vì cái đấy là ra dậy
ở trên chỗ mình học học môn đấy Phải
Tổng cộng là ba bốn lần rồi ngồi ở
trường mình học nhá cho nó hồi mình đi
dạy học thầy cũng có dạy lại mình phát
nữa Để xem mình có dậy muốn lấy không
mấy vẫn không Mình thấy là thời gian nó
vẫn khó quá khó hiểu cái cách dậy của
mình được không thể lý thuyết được như
thế mình kiểu Minh tiết kiệm nó gì đó dễ
hiểu dễ hình dung hơn đấy Sau đó thì họ
có liên thông này mình được họp nhóm nữa
tổng cộng và 34 lần liền đấy nhưng mình
vẫn cảm thấy nó vẫn quá khó hiểu đến
chính mình còn chưa làm rõ được hết nên
Thực sự để mình không thể truyền đạt
được cái đấy à
à à
Ờ Ờ bạn kia nói việc là mình tán ngại
nhiều nên là có nhiều thí nghiệm thì
cũng đúng ở cũng sai sai ở đây là bởi vì
có một sự thật đó là tôi từng trải qua
rất nhiều mà thấy mỗi mà bạn đều có kiểu
khác nhau đương nhiên là mình có thể áp
dụng nhiều kiểu và bạn đấy cũng có thể
ghi nhận một phần nào đó nhưng thực ra
có ở dùng từ ghi nhận ở thực ra là ví dụ
điển hình con gà rỗi để hạn mỗi con gái
rỗi thì ông phải dỗ một chỗ khác nhau
không biết được rồi hài vãi chưởng còn
nhiều Đỡ ngày rỗi mình chỉ cần cho ăn là
được nhiều hơn cái rỗi mình pha trò cười
được nhưng nhiều hơn đáy rỗi thì nó theo
rất nhiều kiểu nói chung à Khó dụng vừa
ăn ở cùng lắm là kiểu khi mà tặng quà
thì mấy ông hiểu có kinh nghiệm này với
ông kiểu tặng có thể là con gái rồi cái
con gà ấy à họ luôn trân trọng với kì
món quà nào của ông tặng lại cho con
miễn nhớ ngày các thứ là được không có
tâm để giá trị của nó cũng nhờ các thứ
còn nếu mà thực sự các bạn để con từ giá
trị khi ông tại bất kỳ ngày nạn được
không cần ngày kỷ niệm I
à à
anh em bị chặn đầy đủ tất cả các loại
thì giờ làm sao có nếu mà ông thực sự
nếu mà ông coi đấy nửa kia không thì ông
có việc thì cối hơn
Ừ nhưng mà thời ra cái tỷ lệ Để Tháp
Anh không làm gì để người ta sẵn ông đấy
thì ra người ta chặn đâu nhỉ Người ta
vẫn có thể một là còn lưu luyến ông
không muốn nhìn thấy nữa thì mày chặn
hoặc là thật sự là người đã chán Có muốn
nhìn thấy em nữa thì ông ông nên biến
mất thật
hai thí dụ mình trầm tính thì cô gái sao
á mình chấm tính đưa ra là ông hãy cũng
gây sự chú ý Hồi trước tôi từng xem vài
bộ phim Vì vậy nó tương tự mà Tôi thấy
thật ra cũng đúng nó kiểu giống kiểu anh
Mạnh Tuấn Anh Nguyễn Tuấn là cái chủ
động đem tán đấy chứ
nói xấu thầy hiệu trưởng Nếu mà đợi khi
thì
cái việc mà ông thường thường xuyên xuất
hiện trước 13 người ta không có ý rung
động ở nhưng không phải đặc biệt hơn
những người khác thì con gái cũng thích
kiểu cu boy lạnh lùng chứ không phải
thích những người người nói ra mồm rồi
là nào giống tôi đâu bởi mấy bạn đấy đôi
khi nghĩ rằng nhà với anh này trải qua
nhiều mối tình lắm cảm thấy cũng
gọi dùng từ mất an toàn hiệu thế
khi sex
có bốn năm đại học không muốn có người
yêu thì thì bình thường thôi Bây giờ bạn
cả đời không muốn có nghề cũng được cái
mình bảo ở không kéo cần nó chạy theo cả
thật xã hội hiểu cả sâu có người yêu thì
mình phải nên có người yêu mình cứ làm
cái gì mình cảm thấy đúng thôi
Ừ mình yêu cả con trai con gái gì đó
mình không hiểu được đúng không ạ Đừng
có làm gì đó Sai sai trái ấy đại lý ở
được
nhà mình có tập gim qua nhá mình bị lưỡi
nhà mình chẳng tập gì mấy
Ừ nhưng mà nếu là sẽ vì tập tập thành
Thì đó mình sẽ thích tập võ hơn này nó
nó cứng cáp và dẻo dai hơn
khoa
học cách nói chuyện học cách nói chuyện
với các bạn phải tiếp xúc với rất nhiều
loại lưới truyền hình các bạn đang đang
nghe mình nói thì các bạn cũng sẽ là một
cách để tiếp xúc của bạn bạn thể tiếp
xúc nghe rất nhiều loại người khác nhau
nữa mình nghe mình nghe rất nhiều Hôm
trước mình có nói lại mình thích xem
nhiều kênh phân tích thuyết trình ấy kể
cả chuyện hơn
Ừ đúng rồi bên bên công ty mình đang làm
là phd
à mà kiểu in theo yêu cầu
à à
cô
bạn kia vừa hỏi về cái cáp gì đó thời
cái gì mình không rõ cái câu hỏi bạn lắm
Mặn hệ inbox riêng mình để mình trả lời
cụ thể hơn nhá Ừ
à à
họ cảm giác mà một người thực ra thì nó
như này nhá Tôi đã từng tán một vài
người
vài bạn ấy thì trong có vẻ là kiểu rất
là năng động ngoài đời nên thấy cái
chính thì bạn đang đợi ngoài đời nên
thấy anh nhắn tin là bạn đấy Vậy ít khi
ý khi con điện thoại để mà trả lời tin
nhắn của ông át mọi việc một phần ở ông
cũng đã là cái gì của người ra đâu thì
người ta phải bận tâm kiểu thường xuyên
on để trả lời cho ông nhưng thực ra một
và ông nên ngắn những cái gì đó Cậu chia
sẻ gì đó hay hay bạn cảm thấy hứng thú
để bạn trả lời lại giống kiểu Ông đăng
Story rồi bạn ấy có thể trả lời trong
Sorry của ông cũng được đấy hoặc là
A ha ra kiểu dạng là ông hẹn Nói chung
không phải tạo ấn tượng người ra chứ ông
đừng hi vọng à ngày ngày nhắn tin rồi
mong cô ấy rung động với cái thứ ba có
khi có mấy ông cũng đang như thế của
chậm thế ơi bạn ấy có đang đi chơi mấy
hôm khác thế ạ Bây giờ mày ông không nên
mong chờ vì nhiều mấy kiểu đây mà Mấy
ông phải à
tự biến cuộc sống mình cũng có kẹo không
phụ thuộc vào kiểu bị mỹ đình nhé
anh Bởi vì người ta đã gì đâu uống lĩnh
người ta đúng không ạ Ông phải có cuộc
sống của ông để mà thể hiện là người ta
muốn bước chân vào cuộc sống của ông có
một sự thật nha Đó là tôi ở từng thấy
mày được mấy bạn gái cậu không biết là
bạn ơi có muốn sống nào hay không nhé
bạn lại có cuộc sống rất là ôi khi mà
không có người yêu rồi Thế nên là mấy
ông muốn được sự một bức tranh và cuộc
sống người ta ấy hiểu người phải một là
không can thiệp nhiều cuộc sống của họ
hay là ông phải có cuộc sống đôi khi còn
còn gọi gọi tốt hơn dùng thì tốt rồi
Không đúng kiểu nói chung là họ có gì đó
rất là kiểu cuốn hút để cho họ cũng muốn
bước cuộc sống của ông chứ không nói
chuyện là kẹo do mà họ đang yên ổn rồi
sẵn sàng cho ông bước vào để phá hết lên
không chuẩn đấy
em inbox cho mình có bất kỳ được đâu
cũng được qua face quá phải cũng đủ
à à
à à Ừ đúng rồi con gái đôi khi vẫn bị
ngại cái việc và nhắn tin trước nên thứ
ca mấy ông có thể đăng Story họ băng bài
đăng thì gió con gái bình luận rồi ông
chủ động nhắn tin cũng được nếu mà ông
là một người trầm tính muốn bạn lấy chủ
động trước thì để mà xe mà bạn lại có
thích mình không ấy thì cứ để ý xem bạn
đấy mà mùa khi bạn này các bình luận của
ông ấy thì một là bạn đấy Cái con người
nhiều chuyện gọi gặp ai bình luận hay là
bạn đấy Kiểu Con người có nói chung và
người ta vẫn có để nếu không rồi nó bình
luận thôi đúng không ạ Rồi hôm nay ở tạm
nhà tâm sự thành ra lại kiểu lượt xem
lên cao vút vậy
Cuối năm mấy ông không có nhiều đi chơi
đúng không
à
mà không nói thế hơi tự ái mai mới đi
chơi xin lỗi xin lỗi
Khi nào này kích thích để mai thực hành
thế anh À và lời kiến thức mà thực hành
nữa Ok em
kiểu chia sẻ livestream cho bạn bè kiểu
Ông ơi cũng một ông thầy đã ngu sẽ ăn
cái anh em vào học áp dụng để mai tán à
à à
em
không kể cả cái việc Cai không mấy ông
bị sao ấy để ông đừng có nghĩ việc đang
độc thân tôi Tôi không nói trên phương
diện là tối đang có người yêu nên là tôi
cảm thấy độc thân sướng hay không mà
đang nói là việc ạ Nếu không được nghĩ
việc đang độc thân thì nó là một sự khó
chịu ý
anh đứng ở Ông đăng người ta thì ra
thường này nó có lấy suốt rồi đó là kiểu
người sống cuộc mấy hiểu hay là
mỗi cuộc cái gì à tình yêu cầu giống như
cả nhà vệ sinh người người ở ngoài muốn
vào học trong Nguyên ra ấy Không Không
nhưng mà ý tôi là kiểu chỉ cần nói ngắn
gọn hoa như thế này mày cũng đừng nghĩ
là là là cái việc độc thân ở con gì rồi
Tôi tắt giống như tôi vừa nói giống như
tôi vừa nói thôi đó là cặp Nếu mà không
Không
khiến cuộc sống mình trở nên thú vị
không bị lụy tình không bị phụ thuộc của
tình cảm quá rồi Bây giờ mình cần nó xem
nó thì cuộc sống này mình sẽ thêm nhiều
màu sắc thêm điều tốt đẹp hơn có thể thế
có thể đâu nha Nhưng mà Mấy ông đừng có
biến cuộc sống nhàm chán khi mà không có
nó
chú chó mấy ông thấy Ok rất nhiều người
đổi bây giờ bị bây giờ tôi thấy giới trẻ
chung nó bị hư bị sao ấy hiểu đang đi
chơi rất vui vẻ vẫn nghĩ nên có người
các như không hề biết được là sau khi có
nhiều khi không được đi chơi vui vẻ nha
này nữa đây thì mấy ông phải thay đổi
cái tư tưởng nó đi đó Ăn gì ạ cuộc sống
mình đang tồi tệ thì mình sẽ phải làm gì
đó
kiếm yêu sẽ là một trong những cách để
mà biến nó cuộc sống tốt đẹp hơn Còn
cuộc sống mình làm tốt đẹp sẵn rồi đừng
có nghĩ rằng là kiếm người yêu nó sẽ tốt
đẹp hơn nữa nóng con người thử kem luôn
than thôi Nhưng mà đừng có nghĩ có thêm
người yêu thì nó sẽ hạnh phúc
Ừ tôi đã nói rồi nó thêm màu sắc cho nó
màu ở đây em chỉ đủ loại màu Có cả màu
đen không đấy
anh hiểu không thậm chí ở hội trước có
bài đăng đấy Đó là la nào giống như hôm
trước tôi nói vụ có còn thế mấy ông Khi
mà chưa Sẵn sàng một mối tình mới ông
đừng có nên kiện Tìm kiếm tình yêu mình
cũng chưa Sẵn sàng nó chưa biết được
trách nhiệm nó chưa biết được à nó có
đem lại cho mình những cái điều tốt đẹp
như nào và xấu xa như thế nào có nhé Thì
mới ông nên nên nên chưa Chưa nên yêu
Nếu có thể kết bạn với nó bạn khác giới
gì đó theo dạng lại Bây giờ rủ hai thằng
đực rựa đi xem bộ phim tình cảm hay phim
hài gia đình trong nó hơi lố thì ông có
thể rủ bất kỳ bạn nữa đó không bảo thằng
với bạn đấy à Tôi đang chuyển một đi xem
bộ phim này tôi không muốn yêu tôi hiện
tại hồi trưa sẵn sàng mối tình yêu đương
gì cả nhưng mà tôi muốn xem bộ phim mai
bạn có rảnh không đi cùng tôi chắn là
bạn ấy sẽ đồng ý thôi đứa phải anh đang
độc thân từ khi à Ừ ông đang có ý đồ mà
làm đi đó còn không thì thực ra là ông
hoàn toàn đi đi chơi vui vẻ với bạn nữ
mà không có tư tưởng gì cả hoàn toàn nổi
không sao cả bạn con gái rất thích điều
lấy luôn bởi chịu khi ở bạn nó có vài
thằng bạn thân khác rồi còn không được
nó rớt ra ngoài và ông hoàn toàn là thấy
cái toàn bộ những cái trải nghiệm - trải
nghiệm kiểu hôn khí thay ạ động chạm cơ
thể thôi còn đâu những trải nghiệm khác
hiểu đi chơi với bạn khác giới nó ra
Bình thường
mấy không nên tư tưởng Đấy dần đi trước
khi mà kiểu nghĩ rằng bây giờ phải trực
kiếm một bạn nào đó của riêng mình đã
yêu
anh Bởi vì một khi mở bạn đấy của riêng
mình đồng nghĩa việc mình cũng là của
riêng bạn đấy Mình cũng sẽ bị chi phối
rất nhiều thứ cũng không đi chơi được
với anh em rồi có thể thử nữa
vân vân vân
em không muốn đi chơi 11 với bạn nữ được
nhá thì ông dù tập thể đi 34 nữa sao ạ
nhưng mà nên là kẹo dạng mà
I Found your một cặp đôi đi cùng đứng
được nhưng nói chung là đừng có bị lẻ
được cả hồi trước bọn bạn tôi rằng hiệu
sau dụng 5 thằng con trai một đứa gái
Mai đứa con gái là như đứa chạy không
được đơn đáng ngại vãi chưởng à
Em bấm vào như thầy Chính thức ppp hôm
nay lạnh quá à
anh lấy vợ thì sao ấy ờ
Chị Tôi chưa lấy vợ tôi không dám chia
sẻ một cái bất kỳ cái gì phải lấy vợ nữa
tôi sẽ mới về việc đấy thì mày Ông hỏi
tất cả những người lấy vợ rồi thì sẽ đều
nói ông việc không nên lấy vợ sớm với
Vân Tôi không biết điều đấy nên là tôi
không nói được cái điều gì cả à
có
việc căn bản tiền ba mẹ nếu không có
người yêu đấy thế cơ à nó nữa đúng như
nữa Không thực ra lại có nhiều không dám
thiện nhất sẽ các bạn phải nuôi người ta
luôn được ra như thế thậm chí là bây giờ
vợ vợ chồng đôi khi ở Tiền nong tự ai
người đấy kiếm không hẳn tựa người để
tiêu được em mình không thích kiểu đấy
Nhưng mà thực ra thì không cần như thế
phải phụ thuộc vào mỗi thằng con trai
kiếm tiền có thể là ông kiếm bạn nữ nó
giàu rồi chú trả được mà
Nhưng mà nếu phải ý là mấy ông hoàn toàn
mà không nên kiểu vì vì hoàn cảnh một
cái gì đó tự ti về hoàn cảnh để mà không
kiếm người yêu
Ừ đúng ạ
chị Mimi ông hoàn toàn là kiểu như tôi
vừa nói thì ra mấy ông phải phải chắc
chắn một vài cái đã có khi mà thực sự mà
muốn khóc phát hiện phát triển mối tình
cảm gì đó còn mỗi khi mà nó trông nó
nghĩ kỹ rồi tất cả những cần Đây Rồi ông
hoàn toàn ổn thôi mà còn những cái yếu
tố khác thì tự nhiên là mấy ông phải sẵn
sàng thời gian cho họ các những thứ tôi
từng thấy vài mối tình mà kiểu người ta
bỏ Yêu 3 4 năm nhưng thử là gặp nhau có
vài lần vài lần luôn ý cho tôi không
phải ở nhà xa chỉ đơn giản là họ không
thời gian mình mấy yêu nhau thật ra đây
không đối với tôi thì là tôi không thích
cái kiểu tình yêu đấy Tôi không biết là
họ yêu nhau nhưng mà tôi không thích
kiểu tình yêu rồi
ở đâu đâu phải là kiểu cái yêu nhau rủ
nhau đi ăn xong rồi tắm thử đó nghỉ để
đi chơi thôi ăn thì ai tự về nhà rồi em
cũng được có sao đâu Và thậm chí là trả
tiền đấy thì nó tôi bảo trân trọng tình
yêu thời sinh viên học sinh như thế cả
hai cùng thiếu thốn thế chẳng ai chị lại
ngay Ai có hôm nay có tiền thì chả đầu
nhọn vân vân theo chị không có tiền ăn
thì thôi Thì kiểu đứng nhìn đứa khác ăn
thì cũng ám vui thôi ông ạ
chị Hà có người yêu thì ông sẽ ăn no hơn
á
Ừ ông nói yêu trạm Hay là ông ăn người
ta vậy
em có kênh discord tính đi code thì mình
có khi discord là cái this code của học
tập chứ không có kiểu Kingsport để tâm
sự đâu nhé á
ừ ừ
À mà thôi hôm nay ủy 47 phút rồi cho
Hoàng Nghĩa mình xin phép à
Ừ tí tí cuối cuối cuối buổi mình sẽ tâm
sự tiếp đến là các bạn muốn hôm nay mình
sẽ nói nhanh trong vòng mười mấy phút
rồi mình sẽ nói qua về vụ qua không mày
học đi
Ừ không thì các bạn hôm nay vào thấy
buổi hôm nay thấy một hàng đang độc
thoại
tiếng đồng hồ để cái việc mà mình ghét
mình đang cay đắng nó không hay lắm ok
à
Bây giờ thì mình sẽ dạy các bạn như các
bạn đã bảo thì mình hôm nay sẽ dạy các
bạn về cái vụ gửi mail thì đầu tiên là
1000 thì mình sẽ dậy nhanh thôi rồi quay
lại tâm sự còn ông ạ bởi vì có vài bạn
vào đây đúng là mục đích họp thôi nên
thành ra là mình mình sẽ vào để mà Hà
mình sẽ dạy học thường anh thôi
anh bởi vì cuối kỳ cuối năm rồi thì cả
mình cũng không muốn à kiểu dạy quá
nhiều các bạn càng khác nó giống như
kiểu trong thời gian nghỉ Tết đi bị
thoải mái thôi từ nên là mình sẽ liện
nhanh cho bạn nào mà vào lê-trịnh nghe
để học sau đó thì sẽ tâm sự sau hi vọng
là tâm sự thì nó không cao nhưng việc
học không cao vào kênh tôi chị nghe tâm
sự cho buổi hôm sau đổi cây mất
thì được thì hôm nay mình sẽ dạy các bạn
vụ gửi mail đầu tiên thì các bạn hình
dung việc là có các bạn bị kiểu gì Các
bạn cũng từng bị spam mail Quảng cáo từ
từ rồi nhưng quan trọng là người ta gửi
các bạn tự động như thế nào sẽ sẵn người
ta phải gửi các bạn tự động chứ không
nói chuyện với thủ công ngồi gõ rồi cả
Xin chào bạn a b c xong rồi copy pate
từng người một không phải đổi tên nó họ
vẫn Vân bạn đã mua gói hàng này hay mật
khẩu bạn hiện tại hay là hay là kiểu bấm
thế này để nhận
để nhận iPhone S mới kiểu thế nó sẽ Star
tự động chứ không nói chuyện là nó ghi
thủ công cho một bất kỳ ai khi cái việc
spam tự động đấy Tôi không khuyên mày
ông ta music nhé rằng nói là tự động gửi
mail cho khách hàng khi khách hàng đăng
ký thành công đúng ạ Đấy có những cái
trường hợp gì có thể tự động được là khi
mà khách hàng đăng ký thành công được ạ
hoặc là khi mà đặt hàng thành công thì
sẽ gửi thông tin đơn hàng đúng không ạ
Cái mà đơn hàng thay đổi tình chạm dụng
ở tình trạng kiểu dạng là kiểu đã đã bị
hủy thông báo đã bị hủy đã được duyệt
thì thông báo đã được hoặc thậm chí là
quên mật khẩu hoặc cả như tôi đã nói thì
kiểu thỉnh thoảng Phantom mà một tháng
một lần một tháng một lần nữa thế là con
còn tương đối được đấy nhiều nơi rồi
Kiểu hàng ngày hoặc là nhà hàng tuần
Steel mill quảng cáo nạn đúng ạ
hoặc là kiểu Milk đôi khi mail cầu dạng
là chúc mừng sinh nhật kèm như đãi đúng
không ạ
thì ra Không kèm ưu đãi gì đâu lừa đấy
mà toàn cả giá cộng lên thôi chứ cái giá
khuyến mãi bằng giá gốc á à à
Ừ đấy nhưng mà Đại Thánh như thế Tôi sẽ
dạy các bạn về cái đoạn ngồi cái đoạn
Miu bây giờ các bạn trao Google gọi ra
đây điểm hình a
pc&cc
email em ạ Mình hôm nay mình sẽ dạy các
bạn với dùng cái mail nhé Thì ạ
ai Có code shop
ở đây này
Ừ
Để chị ông xem nhé kéo xuống rồi anh sẽ
có đoạn Giờ đây đủ mẹ vụ gửi mail
300 hỏi code này
à à
Ừ anh có tính có ngày anh sẽ dậy tính
phí không Ờ trả lời câu hỏi ngải
từ hôm nay tôi tôi được nghỉ tết à nghỉ
Tết dương vẫn đi làm
Ê ngày mai tôi vẫn được nghỉ tôi vẫn đi
làm Ngày kia vẫn thế
em có một sự thật thì tệ đừng nói rồi đó
là tôi làm vì đam mê và nhớ hơn cho anh
sẽ là thực sự tôi hết đam mê ở sẽ không
làm nữa
còn mỗi khi ở tôi bị thiếu thiếu tiền
Thực ra tôi vẫn có tôi vẫn còn thỉnh
thoảng đi trả góp mà đi vay Người Vay và
người thân thôi thôi ngại vụ vai người
lạ ám vai Bạn bè với thực sự thì nó bị
ảnh hưởng tình cảm rất nhiều mọi người
thân ở đây ăn Chị cũng mới mẹ thôi gia
đình khó mà vai đấy thì
ờ ờ mục khi mà tôi bị thiếu thốn nhưng
được ca tôi vẫn có nhiều cách để mà Kìa
mức tiên may mắn như thế
em còn về việc mà dậy tôi tới xác định
một cái gì đó là đam mê rồi sẽ không để
cho cái đam mê đã bị ảnh hưởng với đồng
tiền một khi nó bị ảnh hưởng bởi đồng
tiền đấy thì nó sẽ không không thể làm
được như hồi mình đam mê nữa mình sẽ bị
áp lực do bị đủ thứ
thì mình sẽ phải làm theo một cái kiểu
hình đứa khác
Vì thế tôi không Tôi sẽ có bữa nghĩ việc
ạ sẽ mẹ tội tôi nói vụ đấy liền thì mấy
lần vay mẹ mà mẹ bảo cả mày bây giờ mày
không có lượng sinh viên cao thế Tại sao
mày mày có thể nhận dạy ngoài kiếm tiền
tại sao mày đi dạy miễn phí qua mạng Vân
Vân có chứ
Ừ nếu mà tôi còn nói mẹ mẹ không hiểu
con
em đứng nghĩa là vẫn đi vay của Huệ nó
vẫn cay nhưng mà hứa Thực sự thì mình à
nghe thế hiện hơi gọi chúng tự ăn bạn
nên thỉnh thoảng ăn bán mẹ ạ
có một lần tôi tiêu hơi nhiều xin lỗi
được tiêu hơi bị cũng đam mê nút Tôi
thích cái gì ở tôi mua kể cả nửa đêm đắt
tiền hơn tôi vẫn đặt mua đặt mua đôi khi
là không phải đợi đến đợt khuyến mãi đầu
chú thể mua nhà nó hơi bị
kiến mà nhiều cũng thiếu à
số mệnh hội cho mình từng dùng cái hàm
gì ý Đợi mình tí mấy cái hàng này trống
mạ quá trình nhưng ở page 72 T8 thay đổi
gì vậy
em thấy nóng cũng ngắn gọn đấy chứ chẳng
có mỗi hàng này
từ TPP mấy nhỉ
Milk thả mail
Mở
báo thức
Ê hồi trưa Tôi phải dùng cái kiểu khai
báo từ từ ghê lắm cơ Con đây Chị đứng
một dòng bạn trông có vẻ ngắn gọn không
con fix cấu hình gì cả hơi điêu của đời
tôi cấu hình nữa thử thử 15 cái đoạn
code đây nó cũng phải day 20 30 dòng vì
gì đấy cơ thì nên là nãy giờ tôi thấy
cái đoạn này trông có vẻ ngắn ngắn tôi
thấy nó sai sai kiểu gì
lâu mình không dùng nó nó chuyển qua cái
đoạn ngắn ngủi hơn à đây đây Đúng rồi
đấy dùng cái thư viện này
ở đây đấy mấy ông thầy này hay mấy dòng
chỉnh trình con fake cấu hình với thứ tự
nhiên mình vẫn có cốt về thôi đừng ngồi
pomelo Đúng rồi đấy mình dùng cà phê mel
chuẩn hơn còn vụ rùng mình gọi tên nó
không đúng lắm đầu tiên thì có code lấy
lấy cái cốt spirel này đang được tải về
sau đó đi mấy ông yêu nó yêu nó thứ cảm
chị đó sử dụng nghệ của nó đây Nói chung
là cốt về và sau nhớ Bởi vì các bạn dùng
Gmail mà các bạn chưa đăng ký cái app
của các bạn với với thằng Google nên lên
áp các bạn sẽ tính ở cái ác không an
toàn Nên là các bạn sẽ phải tắt cái đầu
tiên các bạn phải Tắt bảo mật 2 lớp cũng
như là tắt chế độ kiểu cho phép chế độ
là sử dụng phần mềm thứ 3 kém an toàn
thì các bạn mới dùng được và bây giờ các
bạn bởi vì bởi vì cái cái này thì các
bạn phải lưu lại mật khẩu của
cho các bạn ở trong cốt đấy là mình xin
phép mình sẽ đăng ký một cái email mới
để mà các bạn tách mình sẽ luôn rồi các
bạn chưa bây giờ mình dùng mail của mình
trong mật khẩu Tắt bảo mật 2 lớp vì tông
vào mày không Tam của tôi hiểu đăng ký
và mình cái chai rượu 18 + thì ra đăng
ký một vài trang ôm một vài tại cha
người tôi có tài khoản rồi
nói dù là không ổn nó làm không hay lắm
Nhưng tôi sẽ không công cũng khai email
của tôi ra đây ok
a tncn các bạn sẽ phải tải cốc về này
không ạ
anh có thể Dũng cũng phone ơn các thứ
thứ
xe
tải một cái file về
à à
khi sex
ừ ừ
ở tp merlo dụng tải về
à à
I Swear tôi xảy ra
Ừ tôi thường em nợ này lên xem trước Ok
nó trong cái thư mục ông ạ
Ừ mình đi lựa chọn tại này ra
anh Bởi vì nếu mà giả sử nó không cho
chung mục với tôi thường mày Thấy chat
tu hẳn cái mục gì đó để tránh việc Star
một đống ra
cho tôi tôi chưa dùng cái này đâu nhé
Ngồi chứ ở đó có kiểu gì nhỉ
ở tại phải tyrwhitt có gì không nhiều
lắm
à à
anh cứ Có code mẫu về xem đã
bí mật khẩu ứng dụng
cho tôi tưởng mai qua để nhờ tôi chưa
biết dùng này thôi Về cưa
cấu tạo 1 cái đăng ký một cái nhanh mà
đúng không ạ đăng ký rồi anh em dùng
chung cũng được anh em đừng có vào đổi
mật khẩu được
anh em mình sẽ tên là
mail.tp à
Chỉ có bọn cốt này ra này yêu cái gì đó
đi quay Ven Đô
cơ bản đồ chợ Ngựa Truy đâu ra nữa
anh không Không có Không bao giờ nên chị
ngay thôi
ở đầu tiên thì cứ chạy thử này đã
à à
Cho xem xe mà có ưu được cái đấy Không
quét cờ bạc khét
Xin Chào Mi ơi à
Ừ đúng rồi Cái này sẽ dùng Ok
thôi cái mình nhớ là có cốt kiểu Thụ
công hơn không phải OB cơ mình nhớ có
liky có thứ
đây này
200 gọi
Ừ cái đó có tía trong một vài opie nha
ấy lại đi qua này cho người đơn giản hơn
này
chứ không phải dùng cái ui kia từ xem
nhé
Ừ ông ấy dùng hàm mưu này
mà tại sao cứ phải yêu nhỉ
cho tôi lâu lắm mà không dùng người hưu
đấy cơ
a-class này nó không ra nó không vào
được cho mày
à à
Ừ cái này nếu mà như thế này phải để
cung cấp thì phải để ở trong xong rồi
phải ạ
à à
cho tôi không dùng như cầu thuần là kết
hợp với pp
Ok có phải lắm Tôi không quen thông cao
hay có dùng kiểu đơn giản ra đi nhá họ
cứ dùng dạy cả nhà đi Chắc kiểu này cũng
sẽ chạy à
à à
U20 phải wi-fi của yêu đúng không Thì
bạn thấy đúng không thử nhé ạ
à à
ở tp màu lâu rồi
chéo này
sau đó đi wi-fi
anh xuống nhá Ừ
ừ ừ
ừ
nếu thế phải đi qua hết cả tay này
Ừ thế thì là MTP
ở đâu đấy
ở
Samsung à
Tik
Tok 3i
ở
đó đây
à à
Ừ đúng rồi tôi còn có một cái file
autoload đấy mà liy hết là được 10 sẵn
rồi đừng quên đấy chứ
À thì ra mình cũng chưa kết hợp kiểu làm
thuần như thế này bây giờ thì mình hơi
bị láo nháo không tí không sao nói cho
hiện tại thì chắc chắn là
không không truy cập được cái file này
đúng rồi không có file này cái này để
chèn thêm file đính kèm nhé Nói chung ở
mình chưa có phải đính kèm mình bỏ đi
này Hoặc là các bạn để thêm sau
cái này là không tìm thấy hốt này có tự
thưởng đầu tiên các bạn sẽ phải trình
Cái này gì Cái này là Gmail gì vậy ạ Ê
mày nhớ Thế sau đó chỉ email và mật khẩu
Tôi sẽ tự đăng ký một cái Gmail mới
Em à mình có cài có bao nhiêu vào trong
này mình không dùng thôi
ờ ờ
a cho doanh nghiệp à
à À
YouTube School
[âm nhạc]
a rare Earth ảnh
mật khẩu à
bí mật khẩu nên là gì nhỉ
copy luôn cả đứng lên hãy cho về dài mẹ
sau
sau đó quay đặc điểm http bỏ đi
lại phải như thế này ok chưa có dấu mày
mất rồi
cũng cũng được
chị bánh bao
ở Xuân thoại
à à
Em đừng có nhánh ở đây em nhé
số điện thoại rồi à
à à
ừ ừ
anh
địa chỉ Email khôi phục
xe tải tôi gắn địa chỉ email và mày
không khỏi khỏi cầu
anh phá ngoạn ngày à ngày 30 tháng 12
năm hay
20 2000 đi
không muốn trả lời
khi nửa đêm ta không Sếp tôi gọi sếp
toàn đúng đấy là lý do tôi sợ tôi Tôi sợ
Có ai đó gọi tôi bởi vì a xếp toàn gọi
tôi bà mất đến bất kia gọi tôi tôi đều
sợ sợ Có ai đó báo bất công
em nghe thôi mà không Đừng có gọi thôi
đặc biệt nửa đêm nữa nửa đêm bật dậy sớm
ở
cái gì
anh
không tạo được What the f***
Vì sao nhỉ
tình
hình ở tên mà còn nó không hợp lệ
khi họ do ở thấy số điện thoại tôi đăng
ký quá nhiều lần rồi
Ừ
để tôi xem nào
Ê mày đăng ký một tài khoản khác đi à
Lê Nguyễn Long
Long Nguyễn
năm 2021
I said rồi
anh đã bị sử dụng mà
Ông xã tôi đến từ tương lai vậy
Cô gái đã bị sử dụng nồi ủ
Ừ chắc trêu
nội thất q&u
à à
Ừ rồi
cài đặt nhiều vợ cuối cùng về sau không
không nhận nhận ra được mình dậy với cô
kia mày nghỉ à
bí mật khẩu vẫn là như thế này Tại cái
bồ
số điện thoại
à à
anh đọc anh số điện thoại em ạ
a169
số điện thoại của sinh viên đấy à
Vì sao bọn tao à
à à
em bỏ qua mẹ bỏ con đi vẫn là nhập này
anh có được rồi bởi vì cái số điện thoại
kia tôi đăng ký cũng khá nhiều Mio Chắc
là nó nghĩa là tôi spam Nhưng chắc chắn
rồi Ok thì bây giờ như tụi nó nói thì
vậy phải Tắt bảo mật 2 lớp Thìa mới Tại
không có bảo mái thay lốp như phải phải
cho phép ứng dụng không an toàn nữa cái
cách thì tốt nhất thì đó là thược có ra
cách để đặt pc Gmail dẫn
nó sẽ thưởng hai hướng dẫn các bạn từ
đầu đến cô ấy
xe tải nó về này vào đây tắt này Bấm ở
đây tắt này đây thì để copy tôi đứng lên
ngày là tốt nhất này copy đường link này
để mà vào Tắt bảo mật 2 lớp
Ừ nó ở đây cho phép cho phép ứng dụng
không an toàn để vào
anh ơi thì tôi
cho tôi cho cái giới tính đấy vì tôi cho
tôi cốt để làm cái email đấy cho mấy ông
dùng mà chứ có phải là để mà tôi dùng
đâu
đấy Cái này các bạn thấy cái này trình
này cổng sẽ 587 chứ không phải là
nói chung và các bạn chuyển chị nào như
này thôi
bí mật khẩu mật khẩu sẽ là
school cách cái bồ này à
Ừ cái vừa rồi nó nghĩa là gì nhỉ Lòng
Nguyễn
quên mất số rồi đấy ạ
à à
khi nãy con mèo chấm com này
a four-star các bạn điện for được
Thị trường phân đánh giống để chở tránh
bị cho tam long trắng ạ tên đằng sau này
như gửi đến cho ai đó tôi sẽ gửi cho
chúng tôi đi tự kỷ
thế là mấy ông xem được luôn
Không Tên Long đi
có thể nhập theo địa chỉ nữa các thứ thứ
trả lời cho ai này thêm cc này tiền PC
Nếu các bạn nào chưa biết thêm thì Si là
cậu sẽ gửi sẽ copy để cái email của ông
anh gửi cho bạn này nhưng mà hợp bạn này
sẽ được hiểu là kiểu kiểu gửi à
anh gọi gửi forward kiểu gửi ạ
A gọi là nói cho bạn này không ai là
người trực tiếp mà ở trong mail nhắc đến
thường sẽ được gọi và ccc con nữa pgd
Cẩm chuyện gửi mặt zanh à cũng ở gửi cho
tất cả mọi người nhưng mà quan trọng là
những cái người trong bị những người mà
nhận được sẽ không thể biết được là cái
người đã được gửi cùng trong PC là gì
Nếu là sự là sự đây về Toàn nhé ông ông
muốn gửi mail với tất cả mọi người nhưng
mà không muốn
người khác biết được nêu của nhau thì
ông sẽ vứt hết tất cả những cái mail gửi
vào trong PC thì cái mail rồi vẫn sẽ
được gửi tới là mọi người nhau mà không
ai nhìn được
người được nhận và lại những ai bởi vì
mail để trong biz zẫn đi thế thôi
Ừ cái cây Miu này hoàn toàn có thể gửi
được cả HTML nữa nếu mà không để khiến
HM được chu sử dụng việc chèn thêm đúng
kiểu như này không ạ Cháu gửi sau
Ok mày nghĩ được đấy
xe chạy thôi
à à
à Không để kết nối
a
photo Connect server
xem nhá hai cái xử smtp Gmail của tôi
không được
I M TP
các axit Kyu là tls những kiểu swore I
à à
ừ ừ
ở đó
if your name Đưa Bảo vào đổi mật khẩu
của tôi rồi nhé
mật khẩu không lấy cơm đây mở được
à à
Ừ ông nào lại vào đổi mật khẩu rồi
em à đợi gì hãng đang ấm ức
ở tại những ngày mới đúng
em có gửi được gọi vậy
anh không được hai vào mẫu giáo rồi
ở đây
em đang nó bị định dạng làm yêu giác
Ừ ok đấy à
à à
Ừ ok đấy Chỉ đơn giản thế thôi thế bây
giờ các bạn sẽ gọi đến file này khi nào
các bạn thể đi qua wifi này luôn cũng
được thì ở mỗi khi mà các bạn làm xong
cái tính năng kiểu tính năng gì đó được
bạn sẽ chèn lên find nhưng mà hôm nay
mình xin phép dạy thêm một tí nữa tí nữa
đó là nếu mà cứ Wifi này thì mới ông sẽ
nhận ra là nó sẽ gửi luôn luôn cái câu
trong ngày đúng không ạ Mình không muốn
đi Này mình muốn sẽ kiểu thứ nhất là
mình gọi đến file này lập tức vào nó sẽ
gửi mail nhưng mà phải gửi mail đến thứ
nhất là phải thay đổi cái cái cái
kiểu gửi đến cho ai này đúng không phải
cứ gửi đến cho mình nhé Thứ hai là sẽ
thay đổi nội dung của mail đóng góp ý
anh không Bởi vì mới tạm nick mà này là
kiểu gì nó sẽ phẳng đều ra thôi
thì thế nên là ạ Bây giờ mình sẽ hướng
dẫn các bạn về phăng trên nghĩa là gọi
đến kẻ hàm đi quay để tay này đã chưa đủ
mình sẽ truyền vào trong cái ham đấy Cái
gì mình truyền vào lại email này tên là
phải càng này Nội dung của email chưa có
thêm tiêu đề xong rồi nội dung cũng được
thường là tôi sẽ không thấy onboard đi
đâu chưa có tiêu đề và nội dung thôi thì
đây tôi sẽ khai báo đây là cái một cái
gọi Phan sinh không chịu
sẽ copy toàn bộ Cái này ở trong này
à à
Âm Nhạc
ừ ừ
ạ
Sau đó tôi sẽ chuyên vào đây là email
này ờ
khi nêm này sau đó thì à con tên là nội
dung này họ body tùy đó sau đó mình sẽ
sửa lại đây thôi mình sửa lại đây là
ở đôla email
Ý là nameberry là từ Bộ hôm nay sẽ là
mình dạy các bạn cái gì đó lực chuyên
sâu hơn một tí dùng để nâng cao rồi cũng
cũng gọi là đúng đi thế nè Tôi sẽ dậy cả
bao cuộc phóng chân thôi đạo trên da đôi
khi sẽ là con fix này số ngồi Global
vipose vân vân Tôi sẽ dậy qua các bạn
mình cái đấy nữa
có ai một con tiêu đề nữa triệu để thay
đổi đi
để sẽ là tựa đề này
Em hãy đợi tiểu đi à
Ừ nó xác chắc sắp chết chuyện con dê này
này
em
đã không không Sắp chết cả tự thay đồ
rồi nhầm ngắn anh có thể xóa bạn này
định được không cần lại thông báo ấy như
này đâu
Ừ cái này Thực ra là cái này thông báo
ra thất bại cũng được
ạ bây bây giờ giả sử ah tôi sẽ làm vụ là
mà tôi sẽ vào lại trang rồi tôi sẽ đăng
đăng ký đông lạnh đăng ký thành công thì
tôi sẽ gửi mail thông báo đăng ký thành
công lại một cái không ạ tôi là mụ Đăng
kiếm nhỉ Có đúng không size F có nhớ có
bộ giáp này được mặc vào đây sẽ là vào
sát này
Đấy Tôi điên toàn bộ Không tin sôi ấn
vào thì nó sẽ gửi thông tin mình đã đăng
ký sẽ được không ạ
sẽ pháp thì có vô set pháp này
sau khi mở Kiều thành công xong hết rồi
Insert thành công này
Ừ thì mình sẽ
thì mình sẽ đi quay cái file mail.tp này
sao gọi đến phân xin nêu thì sẽ gọi đến
đúng như này thôi mình sẽ chuyển bốn cái
lúc nào bốn cái đúng rồi là email này
nên và mình sẽ có tiêu đề ở đây mình sẽ
đặt hai thôi ngoài đi chưa đề là đăng ký
thành công em ạ ạ
Hà
Nội dung là con tên này các bạn có thể
đặt tên biến khác mẽ cho các bạn với
chuyển đủ số biến là được đây à
Chúc mừng bạn
đã đang đi nhận dài
iphone12 promac nữa
vui lòng bấm Bảo Linh sao để nhận lại
sau đó thì được thế a này à Ừ rồi Linh
Uy tín hạn
giờ đây sẽ là hạt lép lại đến một cái
trang web
hacker.com Mẹ nắng
hay kit.com này bạn nó bị hack ngay cả
thế
à à
nghe trộm nhẹ đúng kiểu dạ
Ừ
đúng kiểu dạng kẹo dạng bạn mail Tam
thật
Ừ nếu không biết sử dụng mắc địa chỉ nhà
tôi không ạ Thế
mật khẩu ngay bạn đăng ký nó sẽ nhớ đến
cái này trong này đúng mà trong uy tín
phết
Anh không ngờ hình giờ đi suốt đoạn này
sẽ bị lỗi vì tôi từng đăng ký tài khoản
này rồi vậy nhưng mà lỗi ở đây lỗi của
Apple Cái dưới Chắc là nó vẫn sẽ chạy
được chạy nha
à à
anh hả Đúng rồi vẫn có kiểm tra này tạm
bỏ qua kiểm tra anh đi làm Bảo Chung
ừ ừ
à à
Ừ đúng rồi có hầm mail của pp rồi Vừa
nãy vừa lại xem là tên nó sẽ AD ạ
à à
à à Ừ nó bảo
diskless không được khai báo lại
Anh phải quay lâu nha là uy tín đấy Cái
này các bạn thấy nó hiển thị một đống
như này bởi vì ạ Các bạn đang để cái cái
này ở Chu tất cả nó hiển thị ra toàn bộ
nội dung kiểu nail gửi nha các bạn đợi
đội nó iPhone nó sẽ không nhìn thấy em
nữa
cô gái trong me linh tinh thế cơ mà
anh vào bên này nhé ở bên này bảo bên nó
spam
Ừ
cái này là do các bạn thấy thiếu gì
không u80 ạ mình phải mình chào Google
cũng được nhớ ở trong này có con Phi kể
trình quốc tế 8 thì vậy
a
police caught đ
Ừ
cái chỉnh u8 rồi nhỉ tôi xem nha Đợi tôi
tí đợi tí
à à
cho mình nhớ là có chỉ muốn đi cốt pp
nhiều lời à
à à
ở
Đà Lạt
anh bình tĩnh bình tĩnh à
xe máy
e-mail lừa đảo mà tiếng việt sai bét rồi
không đi Tí nổi
Ừ cái này info thôi nhớ đội nó phone mẹ
để xem Ở đây đây ở đâu Ừ đợi tí nhé Có
một cái để mà đội đi Bắc
hôm nay đang phải tắt đi nữa tất cả à
à à
có
chuyện
đội nó phone ở đó
em không nhớ của nó phone vậy Ừ rồi thôi
tạm tắt nó đi kiểu gì vậy đó đăng ký
thành công đó Linh Uy tín bấm vào sẽ nhớ
đến trang khách phục gì đó đúng không ạ
lại thế được rồi
à à
em không nghe Mà có khi là cái link ở
trong kiểu như thế này rồi xong rồi có
chữ IPhone 12 bộ mắc ở kết hợp với Linh
khi người ta bấm đấy
ra để không đọc được chữ rồi
ok đại khá như thế
ừ ừ
Ờ Ờ mình có cài vài crackinh các bạn lên
Linh à
từ
rock pop của mình để mở xem xe mình chia
sẻ tí nhé đấy à
ừ ừ
Ừ
cái đại khái như thế rồi Các bạn thể
chèn cái này vào mọi nơi có các bạn muốn
chen không ạ đấy chứ K như tôi đã nói
thật ra bộ hôm nay nếu mà cốt thì nó chỉ
ngắn hơn mẹ lấy giờ mấy ông thấy Thực ra
tôi chỉ có cốt về tôi xử ở chính ông ạ
Đấy Thế làm xong được một tính năng hồi
ngon lành luôn đúng không ạ
em còn bảo là tại sao nó chạy được thì
chịu
anh em áp dụng thư viện ở ngoại ô
Ừ đấy là chỗ nào đại khái Thế còn bữa
hôm nay chắc là tôi chỉ chia sẻ trả lời
hết động cơ họ này đâu
à à cô ấy cậu ấy Bọn này thế nào rồi Anh
sắp nghỉ Tết chưa thì tôi nói với tôi
làm xuyên Tết nó chẳng khái niệm gì còn
đã nghỉ cả
những cái câu kia thì cho tôi sẽ trả lời
sau nhé ạ
đã trả lời vào buổi 6 lưỡi còn buổi thứ
bảy chỉ là mình sẽ nói hết phải đồ án mà
không ạ với thứ bảy lạnh sẽ về đồ án
nhưng bây giờ lại đến trên mục tâm sự
cuối cuối buổi trong khi ông khi mào mới
ông chán không muốn giao lưu tâm sự nữa
thì tôi sẽ đi ông ạ
anh tâm sự cuối năm mà mày không có gì
giải tỏa tâm sự
cho tôi sẽ tranh thủ đọc bình luận xem
mấy ông ạ
bình luận gì tôi tôi trả lời được rồi
trả lời
em
nghe nói yêu ai đến lúc thì sẽ có điểm
Trà đúng không Ờ thế từ yêu nó khác với
sự thích thích kỷ có chán yêu thì nó sẽ
rất nhiều cung bậc cảm xúc và sẽ có ghét
luôn nhưng mà chán nhưng mà
nhưng mà khái niệm về yêu thì nó sẽ đôi
khi là đi cảm với cả trách nhiệm nữa các
bạn không để lại mọi kiểu bạn là tặng
Thôi được hết các em rồi hết thích không
không nói dùng được hết yêu được thật là
một khi các bạn dùng để yo thì các bạn
sẽ theo diện tích rất nhiều không có
chuyện hay tình cảm được một người
Ừ thế là khó mà hết yêu được một khi ở
các bạn hết Yêu thì nói chuyện hơn là
các bạn hết cảm nắng một người ở đó thì
đúng hơn thì ạ
Ừ nhưng mà nó sẽ phải đi kèm với trách
nhiệm
Ừ ông không đẩy nào kiểu cho người ta
niềm tin ở cùng dẫn là nhìn tin lấy được
cho tôi chỉ nói thế thôi
à à
nhà
mình có cảm giác bạn thích mình hai đứa
thích nhau nhưng không dám nói giờ khác
khác lớp nhìn mặt nhau còn ngại à
ạ Bây giờ ông nhắn tin được như vậy tôi
bảo đi
Tao có cái về xem phim này đi không Tao
đang kiếm đứa đi cùng nhưng mà bọn bạn
bận hết rồi lại nhắn Đúng thế hả
Ừ đúng rồi sao rất thoải mái trả lời
xong lại ngại bởi vì kiểu thích nhau đi
ngại bây giờ nhau ngại thì thì thằng
khác nó hết ngại hộ ông ạ
Ê này nhìn nhau số 2
Ừ anh đánh game gì trên steam mình Đánh
Dota thôi
những thường hay thỉnh thoảng vào CF bán
tự do giải trí
bắn theo đầu đội toàn gặp pháp sư trung
hòa giữa cái gì cùng hương đất bạn ạ
chưa bao giờ dạy khóa nâng cao đúng rồi
Ở mình nói mình nói qua trước này các
bạn xem qua ở đây thì mình có có ghi rõ
ở đây là ngày chấm đợt 1 của bảo vệ của
cái đồ ăn một đấy sẽ là sau Tết âm nhưng
mình vẫn nói mà nên ở trong tháng 2 thôi
Bởi vì a nếu mà sau Tết âm Tôi thấy đó
tâm nó là ngày mùng mà từ ngày mùng nói
Trúc Hà Nội phạm vi cậu đầu tháng 2 rồi
mà đến cuối tháng hai mấy ông vẫn chưa
bảo vệ thì chắc là bay hết chữ mất mà đã
là mình hết sự cái dậy sau đấy rồi bây
giờ mình dậy Cái đấy thêm nữa thì thành
sư cái nữa Cái đồ án nâng cao rồi nên là
để bảo vệ cũng phải tương đối sớm hơn
một tí sau Tết âm khoảng một khoảng thời
gian này Nói chung là mấy ông bay hết
cái đầu tiên là bay hết bánh chưng nghĩa
được tâm trục lại ngồi làm việc một like
thật ổn định rồi bảo vệ luôn Nên là chắc
là thằng ba thì sẽ là ngày sàng dạy nâng
cao
à à
ừ ừ
Ê
thằng bạn em làm mấy cái tool Facebook ý
thức mình đừng băng khá nhiều Tôi
Facebook ở trên dĩa hát Đổi bây giờ thừa
mình khó dậy các bạn bè trong Facebook
mình không Trước mình còn nói qua thôi
mình khó dậy được các bạn một phần là
bây giờ thì nhắn ở Liên quan Token nó
khá vấn đề chứ À các bạn mày mò với cái
đấy nó dễ bị khóa tài khoản lắm bởi
thằng Facebook rồi nó khá nó khá là cắt
mà mới ngủ đấy là tôi không hướng các
bạn làm cái vụ này nữa các bạn chỉ cần
đến biết qua thôi làm gì đó mình biết về
lập trình ra mình có thể làm mọi thứ
mình muốn nhưng mà đừng có màu vạch
thẳng Facebook nhiều khóa tài khoản buồn
Ngồi chắc tôi
Cho tôi chơi thử game lỡ lời chưa
mình sẽ trả nó chơi có khi trước bạn tôi
khẳng định đấy Về đi tôi hình như tôi
chơi cảm ứng từ 11 12 rồi
ngày mà hồi lớn ơi con sẽ nổi Việt Nam
Khi bữa nay ở Bà Rịa tôi cứ ra quán net
có thể cho hay hai kiểu moba thử à
Ừ nhưng mà tôi bỏ nói cho bộ cũng hơn
một năm rồi
Cho tôi chơi thể nhờ tuổi cũng không nạp
tiền lắm đâu
ai dọn tôi buồn à
nghe giọng tôi rồi chắc chỉ muốn ngủ với
vợ không có buồn gì cả
à mình làm để chắt bóp
a sport mình từng làm rồi chắc bóp để
ngắm đá nằm rồi con sẽ post với Zalo
được cái Zalo được cái từng tìm hiểu qua
tài liệu của nó rồi ra mang tiếng là
chẳng hiểu sao hồi đấy tìm hiểu nhé Nghe
lời là của người Việt làm mà tài liệu ra
ngoài nhanh sai chính tả
em không có tài liệu tiếng Việt cái vậy
Không biết bây giờ thế nào nếu không lấy
tội từng làn khá khó chịu về khi mà kết
nối vào Zalo vậy ạ
ờ ờ khi em vào thực tập công ty đưa tài
liệu cho đọc đúng rất nhiều công ty giờ
đang làm ở thế tục là không hẳn tôi thế
nên tôi người bảo là bây giờ để các bạn
thực tập vào một công ty mà nó Lý Tưởng
làm chị người ta đào tạo người ta Cậu
cầm tay chỉ lỗi do người ta đào tạo một
cách nghiêm túc cũng như tử tế các bạn
nói ít lắm như hồi trước của mạng mình
rất là may mắn như mình gặp được người
như thế Kể Người thầy đầu tiên của mình
ngoài đời anh đấy rồi Hôm nay chị lỗi
Mình hỏi mình hỏi liên tục hỏi rất nhiều
cũng rất nhiều thời gian anh đấy mà anh
ấy có được thêm cái Đông Lương ở đâu Anh
có tốn thời gian rồi anh đấy cũng như
anh đang làm việc riêng làm làm việc của
anh đấy nữa đúng không ạ
Vì thế nên là mà anh ấy vẫn chịu khó trả
lời mình cái thứ hư sao anh con từng
khuyên mình là anh ấy là cổ đông công ty
luôn này công ty cần phải xa lắp mà anh
còn thường khuyên mình nếu mà công ty mà
bây giờ em đừng cái ngưỡng ngọn không Họ
hỏi thêm được gì mấy nữa rồi cũng như là
bởi vì cái anh giám đốc ơi anh giám đốc
anh ấy đang cậu vẫn đang trả lương mình
rất bèo bọt đâu anh nhớ bà rồi Nếu mà em
cảm thấy kiểu muốn thu nhập có vấn đề
Thế thì chắc là em có thể nghỉ được vì
sao em thấy cân nhắc quay lại tùy em
ngoại nếu bạn anh hồi trước anh cũng
từng như thế với thầy của anh chưa cả
anh ấy cũng từng
Ừ nghỉ cũng tương tự là trong mọi người
cũng hiểu cảm giác trong trường hợp hoàn
cảnh của mình là anh ấy đừng bỏ không đi
xe grab một trước vì thế
ở trong anh về tâm lý lắm và hiếm có kẹo
Công ty nào kiệm như thế nên là mình
khuyên các bạn là khi em vào công ty lớn
thì nó sẽ không ai vứt các bạn một cái
tài liệu đọc hoặc là cho các bạn và than
vào hạt một cái bộ bạn ạ phòng ban riêng
mà phòng ban thực tập thì các bạn sẽ
không hoạt động bao nhiêu cái nướng ở
bên FPT Shop hỗ trợ Thế
hôm trước thôi Bây giờ mình có biết là
sinh viên mình đánh giá ở giữa là như
thế kiểu đào tạo nó không hẳn đã mình
không được động vào việc tế mình kiểu
không không biết được nhiều thử thực tập
xong mình chẳng biết mấy mình tự học
nhiều còn nếu mà Mấy ông muốn thực sự đi
thực tập mà được bài bạn được anh đào
tạo lại từ đầu một cách tử tế thì hiếm
bởi vì đôi khi nó ký bát ông và ký xác
nhận kiểu khi mà thực tập xong vậy làm
cam kết làm bao lâu nữa
cho
tôi thì tôi khuyên mày ông vào công ty
sát ngay lúc đâu trong để người ta để nó
học họ được nhiều hơn được làm động chạm
nhiều hơn trước công ty lớn thì thì
tuyến
ở kênh nào nước ngoài dạy cơ sở rượu dễ
hiểu không ạ gần đây mình có xem 1 vài
kênh cho mình chưa đề xuất được một cái
nào cụ thể dạy về cái này chủ yếu do các
là chứng tài liệu của nó đầy đủ nhất
chẳng có một cách nào dậy cơ sở liệu dễ
hiểu cả
vì anh nghĩ sao về bệnh tình cảm á Hồi
trước rồi cả tôi từng nghĩ cho tôi bị
trầm cảm
khi xem cảm với đây ở hội không phải bởi
vì tôi nói nhiều Không phải cái trầm cảm
thứ nhất là không phải việc người nói
nhiều người nói ít chân gà lắm chuyện
với ta sẽ cậu sẽ kiểu giả là theo cho
tôi hiểu nhé trầm cảm à Ở phim khi mà họ
buồn không lý do hay họ còn nhiều yếu tố
nữa cơ Thế nên là số ca rất nhiều người
nghĩ ra cái kiểu tôi cái thì thoại có
buồn thì tôi bị trầm cảm khi trước Hội
nghị hết nhiều không trầm cảm nó hẳn gọi
là bệnh thức làm chị ở họ không kiểm
soát được và họ sẽ kẹo họ đôi khi còn
làm những cái gì đó gây hại bản thân
giống như ở cậu vân vân nữa họ làm một
cái kiểu không ăn vô thức nhưng mà họ
kiểu dạng là họ tự nhiên bị trầm xuống
bị chậm giống kể cả đang vui tự nhiên bị
nhầm uống anh chị đấy mới ngủ gọn mới
gọi là bệnh
em có những bạn bây giờ kia tao chứ
thằng yêu xong tao buồn quá Tôi trầm cảm
đấy cái đấy không phải là bệnh gì cả vì
bệnh xong các bạn vẫn thể hơn họ được
ngay sau đó thì đúng không phải bệnh
à à
anh nói suy nghĩ của nóc nhà sim được
thầy tàn đã hết sáng là bạn ấy sẽ cử
được câu đầu tiên bạn ấy sẽ nói là kiểu
nhất là trẻ trâu thứ hai là dai vì hồi
đấy à Hồi mà tôi ra hồi đầu tôi gặp bạn
đấy là bạn đấy có người yêu rồi nhưng mà
đang có vấn đề gì đó là lúc anh tự có
nghĩ tôi biết lại có nhiều rồi nhưng mà
tôi không hả tán đâu lần đầu gặp lần bạn
đợi ý ra Hà Nội lần đầu tiên cũng mà
các bạn đây ra để sinh nhật nhóm chưa
tinh công ty thì tội thì cái anh em rủ
nhau đi ăn chúng tôi các bạn đấy thì thì
bạn Sau đó thì tôi hiểu và nói chung là
kiểu cũng tạo ấn tượng bạn đấy Cái thứ
xong rồi tôi còn Tiên lại ra sân bay nữa
nhà hàng Trung Hoa kiểu
ạ
Bạn ấy bảo bảo là ghét Hà Nội vừa đã
từng thử cái như bà Tùng ra Hà Nội một
lần Nhưng mà thực ra là cái bà không
không trải nghiệm nhiều vợ bảo Hà Nội
kiểu chán hơn ở trong kia thành ra là
kiểu Tôi muốn chứng minh với bạn đấy là
Hà Nội có rất nhiều cái tốt đẹp Hãy cứ
thư thứ ạ sau đó Đương nhiên thế sao
cũng chả được gọi ra đây
đến bây giờ vậy Mới ghét Hà Nội Vì Hà
Nội lạnh vãi còn sẽ không lạnh đấy anh
không quen ai được biết ở đây nhưng mà
đấy bạn đấy thích được một cái nở đó chỉ
vì một con người mấy ông phải thay đổi
được như thế
Em thấy có tài liệu là không á Mình có
có tài liệu leo và cỏ có cả khóa học các
kiểu thứ năng nhưng mà nó nâng cao còn
nếu mà các bạn Nếu bạn đang muốn các bạn
thì như mình đã nói để hạ trang chủ nóng
và đọc thế thôi ừ ừ
ở tp nâng cao để chuyển tagged ấy còn
ở tp cơ bản thì thực ra mình dạy nó trẻ
mức cơ bản cơ bản của cơ bản thôi còn
nếu các bạn muốn kiểu cơ bản và thêm
Rộng hơn thì đúng là mấy kênh mình bảo
cốt academy hãi đá với bà school mà còn
thêm rất nhiều cái nữa rồi
Ừ mình qua Rô ta mình có cho ta bởi vì ạ
Giờ nó bị nhàm chán có mình thích có gì
đó cậu mình mẩn suất Chơi game mình cũng
thích kiểu cha hót cậu cô kiểu cố gắng
hơn chục các thứ thứ
Ừ
đúng rồi cho ta khó chơi hơn nhưng mà
chín vì thế nó sẽ lọc Đỡ bớt trẻ trâu Đã
lâu rồi mình sẽ chạy Chậu nhiều vãi
Kiểu cái đúng ở Dota thì nó được cái nó
kiểu chụp ảnh tượng nặng kiểu không tôn
trọng người khác nhưng mà ý là bọn nó
chơi vẫn còn chơi gọi hai mình vẫn còn
thấy kiểu có gì đó đánh ai học hoài còn
lỡ lời thì mình thấy ở gấu trẻ trâu kết
hợp việc hơi tí nữa tự ái rỗi thôi chửi
nhau
an toàn bộ những cái tài liệu mình sẽ về
sau Thứ nhất là khi các bạn nào bảo vệ
đoán một thành công mình sẽ chia sẻ các
bạn tài liệu nhé các khóa học có thư với
nữa với những nhóm bảo vệ thành công
thôi mình đưa mình ở chơi sẽ trả lan quá
rồi cả nó không tôn trọng nó già lắm rồi
tao bạn bỏ tiền mua không có phím mà
mở mạng chứ hà nội mạng kim cùng trong
nhà mình thì à
em có mở điều hòa thì đâu cũng chẳng có
lo sữa vậy cả
anh không mình không đập chậu cướp hoa
rồi nhé bạn đấy
Nói chung là thời đấy lại chờ đấy Kiểu
gặp như thế thôi sau đó đi ỉa phải phải
vài mấy mấy tháng sau khi mà tôi bị thất
tình cái còn thất tình đấy tôi tra bây
giờ đang tâm sự với tôi chia sẻ nhé
Nói chung à
Ừ cũng đúng đúng thời gian này năm đấy
năm đấy là như 5ha 2 năm trước phải 2
năm nữa nhỉ
anh 2019 Nói chung là tôi bây giờ tôi bị
bị mất khái niệm 10 năm tháng rồi nói
chung à
Thì có kể với ông nha
và cũng chính ở vườn nãy tôi bảo việc là
tôi nhắn tin thường xuyên với một người
mà người đấy có cuộc sống riêng với họ
không còn gì nó gì thì nó là như thế
được lại mình nó nhắn tin sau đó mình
gặp muốn kiểu rủ mày đi chơi xong rồi
cậu Cuối cùng thì ok bạn đồng ý nghĩa đi
chơi vào đúng ngày 31 gọi là cùng đón
giao thừa
ở đây sau đó đi à
anh Tốn lấy thẻ bạn tôi chuẩn bị hết các
thứ ở tôi đi dạy học xong kiểu về chuẩn
bị các hư rồi bạn ấy bảo là có đúng phát
đã nhắn tin khi mà mình đợi để gần đến
rồi thì bạn nhắn tin à mà không quá rồi
Ở đợi mãi bạn mình nhắn tin à à
Ừ em đi ăn tất niên với công ty anh đi
em trước đi kê em mình lại đi ăn sau đó
đi hôm đấy Kiểu buổi gặp đầu tiên nhưng
mà tôi đã mua quà trước cho bạn đấy rồi
Tại sao lại mua quà của vì a trước đấy
hôm giáng sinh
bạn đấy bảo là bạn ấy khoe bài thi thi
đạt điểm cao rồi tôi bảo tôi sẽ mua quà
giáng sinh thưởng bạn đấy cái tô mua hạn
quà chưa cho người lần đầu tiên gặp nhé
Ok có thể rất lãng mạn ăn thử thôi đi ăn
thì ăn một mình buồn rồi lỡ để tối qua ở
giọng ở ngoài xe bị
bệnh mất đấy ra ngoài phải mất quá lại
phải chạy đi mua thêm món quà nữa từ gói
tao thử cẩn thận đấy các thứ con gấu
bông thôi Đấy xong rồi à
anh bình luận nơ đợi em về nhắn tin khi
đi ăn tất nhiên xong Ok bạn kêu là bạn
đã làm ở Viettel post ở đấy Sao rồi bạn
đấy ở Cầu Giấy tôi lượn ở ba cái Viettel
post ở Cầu Giấy vào đêm ngày hôm đầy
lạnh vãi hai tiếng đồng hồ từ 8 giờ tối
10 giờ tối em mới vẫn trên một cái gì cả
sau đó thì 10 rưỡi em mới nhắn lại bảo
là
anh ở đây không wi-fi nên là không nhắn
được
à Thế bây giờ thì đương nghe em bây giờ
nhắn tin thì em phải đang ở đâu Em bây
giờ ở nhà Okay Sao bảo thôi bây giờ chắc
không đi đâu nữa Thì mình muốn qua đưa
quà ở về chẳng ấy bác qua về cho vợ rồi
em về từ chối không nhận
cho tôi biết ở bị đau cây rồi
Thế thôi đợi nha
Anh đang về
những cái lúc mà buồn như thế Chúng ta
sẽ làm gì không Chúng ta không đi giải
quyết bằng rượu bia chúng ta sẽ đi nét
vui rồi Thằng Sinh Viên bỏ tôi
đó nó hư ở trong con mắt thâu đêm để tôi
toàn có cái gì cả Buồn vui đi nên nó
giải quyết hết đi Lady đêm bị Nó là một
cái gì đó kiểu trải nghiệm và rất là hay
ở điểm thứ nhất là không gian không khí
nó âm đấy nó khác với đi hết ban ngày
rất nhiều nó không có cảm giác mình rõ
sôi động đó là sự châm láng nó sự kiểu
theo dạng này nhiều bông còn bảo đấy
ngồi tâm sự giống như tôi luôn vào đấy
ngồi chơi đến 2 tiếng Ồ tôi mới bắt đầu
ngồi tâm sự
Ừ tao đặc biệt ennis đêm uống rượu nó sẽ
bị mệt rã rồi nó na ná giống như mấy ông
sai Nếu sai để ông quên đi một cái gì đó
thì tôi đi nét vừa để quên và và để cho
Khi say thì ông sẽ đi tiểu không kiểm
soát được ông dễ rất là buồn của ông sẽ
mệt ông ngủ thiếp đi vào ngủ sâu được đi
nét thâu đêm nào cũng thế ông sẽ khi mà
không đến 5 giờ sáng vội ông dễ không
ông lúc này em chỉ muốn ngủ thôi vợ ông
ngủ một phát luôn chứ bây giờ bảo Ông về
ngủ cái ông sẽ chăm chẳng cũng có chịu
rồi đó ấy nên tôi Thực ra nó vẫn xấu nó
vỡ nợ xấu tôi không kiên mấy ông như thế
nhưng mà ý tôi là tôi thả chọn được đấy
còn hơn tôi uống rượu bia tôi tôi là
người không rượu bia không hút thuốc
à à
ở
đây ông kia vừa hỏi là có nhậu không em
Ừ đúng rồi tôi toàn vụ sinh viên em à Rủ
một vài được cả thôi hợp hợp mình thôi
Ừ thế ấy sau vụ giao thừa rồi đúng không
Rồi à tiếp đến nữa
tôi có quen một bạn
phụ đề nữa
đến tháng 2 tôi lại nói chung à năm đấy
tôi đã mất niềm tin và
năm đấy tôi bị thất tình như thế Tôi cay
thôi Ok tôi tôi kiểu
phải đến tháng 2 tôi mới bắt đầu Lấy lại
tinh thần ổn định một tí cho tôi lại vào
công cuộc Tân Khai cũng kiểu vô tình
thôi Nó là thấy một bạn đăng lên trên
cái Trang à cái Ngó Granite Việt Nam Bạn
thường Anh dịch bài Thất tình sao mình
nghỉ buổi khi bạn ở hợp mình lại cũng
tầm mã bằng tuổi đó rồi các bạn thường
em đang bày hết tình có nghĩa là bà ấy
cũng kéo cũng có suy nghĩ gì đó đông
cảnh về chuyện tình cảm sau nói tôi thấy
nhắn tin vậy đấy đúng à Hai người rất
hợp nhau và vân vân có về dưới nhưng mà
hồi đấy Dịch nên chưa gặp được sau đó
thì đến nữa à từ 14 tháng 2 ngày vai hay
khi bạn chia tay thôi à
ở đó thế này là
khi bị thêm một quả đấy nữa à
mẹ tôi lúc đấy thật sự đi nghĩ rằng ạ
đau đau đấy nhưng mà rồi kể kiểu là mình
kẹo mình Thực ra tôi rồi đấy rồi dậy tôi
cậu à
khi trưởng thành hơn so với bạn cùng lứa
ở kiểu mình có thu nhập mình có tài
chính các hướng sự nghiệp có phải ổn
định ngồi thì vừa mình thường anh nghĩ
chợ tình cảm mình cũng có thời gian rảnh
buổi tối bọn bạn vẫn còn đang đi làm
không rủ đi chơi cái tôi hiểu được mình
muốn hẹn hò lúc đấy Nhưng mà thực sự hơi
cổ Khi khó
a free thường tầm tuổi mình đến lúc phải
Bội vẫn đang đi học hay đi làm kiếm tiền
với bạn nhỏ hơn như vậy vẫn còn nặng tư
tưởng cái gì đói à
anh nói chung là lúc đấy tôi nghĩ à Có
khi lúc này kiểu gì mình cũng không nên
động chuyện tình cảm thời gian này nữa
nhưng mà khi mà bị kiểu bị rảnh khóa lâu
thì cứ thả nên mấy ông sẽ ngồi nghĩ
chuyện đấy anh cách nhớ nhất tôi đấy hơi
đầy đó tôi cứ kiếm một bạn nào mà nhắn
tin cho bạn ấy thoải mái mà không không
yêu được cô tô quyết định nhà nào bạn
nóc nhà này bạn ấy đang trong Sài Gòn ở
xa với trường rồi tôi không nghĩ là bạn
sẽ ra đây
rồi Cuối cùng thì đấy tôi Tôi từng nói
ông một bài học xương máu nữa rồi đó là
kiểu mà Ông nhắn một người đó rất là
bình thường không với định gì
ở địa tán rất là dễ thương ô tô kéo nó
bảo ra đây à
ở đấy có chuyện của tôi khi mà và và cái
thời gian mà tôi nhà nó bạn đấy cũng có
lúc rồi vậy chứ Đang ỉa rồi không không
nên đã bạn đây cũng và thứ ra chia tay
người yêu cũng khoảng thời gian rồi nghe
bạn cũng không dư luận người yêu cũ nữa
vi
phạm đường tình tôi chắc Châu Á yên tĩnh
Tôi tôi một kể ra nó có một tiểu thuyết
tiểu thuyết kiểu nón nửa nửa buồn cười
đừng buồn cười nữa buồn đấy nhưng mà như
là nó rất nhiều đấy hàng ạ Mà mấy ông mà
nghe giọng với ông sẽ không biết Anh
nghĩ tôi là con người như thế nào nữa à
ở những đại khái nam đấy 5 kiểu rất là
biến cố có nữa à
bài hát nóc nhà tôi 5 nhà tôi nghe biết
để mà
tôi bảo tôi lúc đấy tôi nhắn nó bận Đấy
nói do tại sao nhắn đấy mà Bởi kiểu sao
rồi Nói chung là hơn một tháng sau đó đi
Bỏ tôi thực ra vẫn nói chuyện như bạn bè
bình thường nhé vẫn được chụp ảnh nhau
là hôm nay đang làm gì có hơi thứ đã
định nói chuyện kiểu bình thường đấy chứ
không như kiểu kiểu tỏ tình thả thính gì
cả rất bình thường hôm nay đi Bà đang ở
đâu Thế bạn đang làm gì đấy cảm thế mà
không có nói bạn bán cơm chưa cơm nhé
Để làm gì tôi đã làm này không ai tôi
gặp cái này cái thứ đấy thế đội dở nhẹ
vẫn bình thường
à à
ở những cứ hỏi em ăn cơm chưa thì em bị
sẽ không có trả lời đâu
à à
anh béo
ừ ừ
vì
anh nghĩ sao về việc gia đình hay người
khác nhau hoàn cảnh gia đình ở
con gà gì à Nhưng mà luật pháp thì cái
nói đó là trước 18 tuổi thì đấy là lỗi
lỗi do hoàn cảnh nỗi lo nhiều thứ còn
sau 18 tuổi toàn bộ những cái Lỗi Lầm
của ông gây ra là do bạn thật đông không
có một thứ đó thì chỉ có nhiệm thay đâu
trừ khi ông bị bệnh gì đó còn không thì
toàn bộ là do quy định cái này là cũng
thế cho tình cảm hay cà phê uống
ta có thể tính cách của ông thế
ạ sau 18 tuổi ông đổi nhận thức các từ
thứ rồi những cách không phải thay đổi
sao cho phù hợp với kiểu nói cho mọi thứ
chuyện tình cảm thế là gia đình hay mọi
thứ không nên tác động trực tiếp và cuộc
sống của ông nữa Ông muốn gì thì ông
phải tự quyết định các bạn ạ
ở đại bế quan điểm của tôi thôi Tuy
nhiên là thở ra nhiều hoàn cảnh lắm kìa
ông và sự ông một mình ông phải gồng
Gánh Cả gia đình ông về nuôi cả em cứ
như ông không có thời gian yêu đương cả
không không để nói tôi cậu
được cho tôi đã nói chung mà nó là thế
mày ông không nên thế Thực ra từ trước
ai tôi không Tôi không tin bỏ toán hay
bất kỳ cái gì một cái gì đó thì quyết
định cuộc sống của tôi kể cả Bố Mẹ mập
tôi không nghe đâu tôi con người hơi bị
cứng đầu ở điểm đấy chỉ là tôi nghĩa
cuộc sống thôi phải do tôi quyết định
vì thế mà không ai ép được tôi cái gì cả
nên là tôi mới bảo là không muốn đồng
tiền chi phối cuộc đời tôi như thế tôi
đam mê rất thích cái gì tôi sẽ ra đứng
như à Không phải là thích cái gì thì làm
bằng được thì nó hơi sai
em có nhiều thứ mà không phải mình thích
là được không ạ Nếu mà chỉ là mình à
Ý mình nói giữ mình sẽ nghĩ nhiều cách
để mà làm cái gì đó nếu mình thích
à à
Em ăn cơm chưa cũng là một kiểu quan tâm
mà Kỷ Tỵ thế
Đúng tôi không kỳ thị nếu quan tâm nhưng
mà Mấy ông hỏi câu nó hơi bị ngắn ngõ
mấy ông thay ý thế Miếu Ông hỏi câu ví
dụ em thích ăn lẩu không Em thích ăn một
cái gì đó không dừng lại vợ anh sẽ có
một con còn mỏ hơn để các bạn trả lời
hơn là một câu hỏi kiểu dạng là nó bị nó
bị nhà đi
Ừ ừ ông hỏi uống nước chưa cần được uống
nước chưa thì nhắc nhở bạn uống nước hợp
lý hơn còn ăn cơm chưa Người ta sẽ ăn
rồi
và nhiều đứa trả lời em ghét ăn cơm về
chưa Đừng hỏi nữa à
anh em xem rau dền không à À ông kia
biết sự tích tao lên đúng không có nhiều
bạn chưa biết về sự tích rau dền
theo là một cách tán gái
ha ha
có nhiều thứ nhạy cảm
bệnh bị bạn nóc nhà đang hỏi mấy giờ
mình đang nói gì
thì sự thích rõ về nó như thế này cho
ông là chưa biết đó là một ông một ông
con trai chưa từng đi tán gái sau đó thì
hôm nay hỏi bố cách tán gái nha Buổi lần
đầu tiên gặp đi hẹn hò con gái ông bố ạ
Có bà chủ đề nói được một lời về ăn uống
hay về gia đình mà về
quan điểm sống mà không về triết lý Chết
đi sống
thôi đứa con trai khi mà đi gặp được em
gái khi mà hỏi han các thứ về thử các
thứ mà hết thiếu gì mạ
giới thiệu rồi thì bắt đầu nhảy sang chủ
đề 1 bé ăn uống đi Anh hỏi là em thích
ăn rau dền không
Dù sao đứa này bảo lạnh lùng rồi thằng
con trai đến hỏi sang chủ đề thứ hai về
gia đình em có anh trai không Không vẫn
một sự rất là lạnh lùng ông ấy lôi luôn
chủ đề thứ 3 mình chỉ như sống hay giả
sử em có anh trai thì anh ấy thích ăn
rau dền không
để thế hết 3 luôn chủ đề Tôi không biết
được
cái kết nối câu chuyện à
Vì thế nên là
hồi trước của cái có về quan điểm đó là
ai mà hỏi là em thích ăn rau dền không
phải chứng tỏ là mình thích bạn
nhưng không biết nói là như thế nào ạ
à à
em không lấy đâu tới sinh viên được cười
nóc nhà đâu em tập tập trung chơi game
em
nhắc nóc nhà tôi Thỉnh thoảng mới có ở
xem livestream thôi
ừ ừ
à à
Ừ Ok mày ông Lẽ ra tôi dậy tôi chia sẻ
nhiều chết mày Ông hỏi han thì đây buổi
giao lưu mà nó ạ hỏi han thêm cái gì
mình sẽ là chia sẻ mấy ông muốn chia sẻ
đi Để tôi tôi trả lời cho
Ồ
tôi thích ăn rau dền không
à Tôi thật ra là con người
em ăn được hơi ít món và ngại thực nó
chút nào tôi bạn tôi cổ phụ có những rất
nhiều cái để thể hiện cái cô hộ tôi là
tôi ngại thay đổi ít mỏi cơ Áo mỏi ngại
thay đổi mà ngại Thay đổi cái ăn uống
thôi Còn tôi tôi là con người thay đổi
khá nhiều theo chiều hướng tốt lên tôi
nghĩ thế
anh
cũng không thay đổi được bản chất bản
thân bạn thân thôi chứ trước này mà như
nào để nó vẫn sẽ là như thế nhưng mà có
rất nhiều cái thay đổi giữa Hồi trước
bạn tôi được 27 thay đổi cảm ứng dụng
anh để hội cái thế đổi đây ạ
à à
em giao lưu đầu năm để giao lưu cuối năm
này mấy ông thắc mắc cái gì mà ông có
chia sẻ đâu giờ thêm nữa làm đi
A
Gọi nằm vừa rồi mấy ông làm gì chia sẻ
ngọn mấy ông cảm thấy khó chịu hay vui
điều gì mẹ cũng có thể chia sẽ
ra đời hội bắt trường của nhân dân để
viết 352 làm gì
anh Hải
Nghĩa Cũ Thực ra là nóc nhà tôi biết khá
nhiều không ăn khá nhiều nhưng nói chung
ạ Cũng biết tôi từng trải qua nhiều mối
tình rồi
khi bảo vệ đồ án có livestream còn
livestream
À thế à Thế thì được ăn nó có hơi tí hạn
chế là kiểu những nhóm trước phải biết
được nhóm những nhóm sau sẽ biết là nhóm
trước hay bị hỏi gì để mà chuẩn bị trước
nhưng mà yên tâm rồi có nhiều câu hỏi
lắm mà kiểu gì mấy ông sẽ sẽ bị bắt lỗi
rồi nên tôi không lo với nghề đấy
anh đi làm sớm từ năm 2 đại học được
không thấy
nếu bạn thích các bạn làm từ 53 à cấp 3
Các bạn đi làm cũng được rồi mà
em yêu xa khó không
á Đối với mình ở khó vì mình thì
thì các bạn phải xác định khi mà các bạn
muốn có người yêu các bạn để làm gì đã
muốn có người yêu để mà có mặt tinh thần
thì được cái là các bạn yêu bất kỳ đâu
được các bạn thật chị yêu yêu
gọi nhiều như quý mũi nhỉ yêu 2D cũng
được Nếu là sử hoa kiểu mất niềm tin vào
con gái đời thật rồi Các bạn hãy chuyển
qua yêu hoạt hình cũng mắc Mục đấy tí
người yêu xa mà đúng ạ Còn nếu mà các
bạn muốn yêu theo cả để mà lâu dài thì
phải sao cưới hay nhiều yếu tố nữa Nếu
cả lao thì phải đi chơi xong rồi nắm tay
thực chứ không phải ảo thì thì sẽ như
nào mấy vợ ở xác định rõ những cái khái
niệm lấy danh mạch các bạn sẽ khỏi khó
chịu không Khi mà không được gặp nhiều
nhiều vào Vân không ạ
nữ sinh Yên tâm hassle-free sơ chứ thực
tập gì ở lại cùng chiêm nghiệm rồi thực
tập
chợ hoa xơi tỉa hoa ctpt của chắc là
không có thai nào tự đủ tự tin là dạy
mấy ông ấy ra cái đây lý thuyết là nhiều
và cái đấy xét là phải kiếm người học
bên
mình mình có chính đại ca của mình mình
từng nói qua đại ca mình rồi dậy bên
quản trị mạng dậy cứ thấy rất là giỏi ra
nhưng mà thấy bị thấy kiểu anh nắm chắc
lý thuyết thấy rất là hài hước hãy rõ
hơn mình nhiều tổ hai
rất nhiều lý do mình gọi bé các đại ca
nhưng mà không biết dạ được anh ấy về
dậy online cái này không vì anh đấy cũng
dậy vẫn dậy lên thường rồi
khi mới ra trường thì nên dành ra 2 năm
để tập trung đi cốt 2 vừa yêu vừa làm
nhỉ
cái cái này cũng là một cái điểm cũng
hơi sai một tí đó là ông xác định được
việc là ông nghĩ rằng là ông ấy thể kiểm
soát được tình yêu à Thế đã sai rồi đứng
nhà tôi không kiên mày không đi tìm tình
yêu Nếu bây giờ sự mấy ông vẫn tập trung
sự nghiệp nhưng mà
á Đối tôi quan điểm yêu mà không kiểm
soát được tình cảm của mình thì đấy
người yêu một khi ông dùng lý trí kiểm
soát được học nó không phải là yêu nữa
nó là nó là kiểu dáng trông tinh toán mà
cái kính yêu rồi
ý nghĩa là Đồng Văn
Ừ ông thấy được một ai mà cảm thấy rất
là cậu không thể tập trung vào sự nghiệp
đấy thì không phải ông cắt đựng mối quan
hệ người ta bàn đấy ông đang có cảm tình
người ta rồi đấy ông kéo
cho nên tại sắp xếp Hòa được cả hai càng
tốt
là một người nội thành một người ngoại
thành
xe ga thì giống như là mụn nhớ bạn nói
rõ hơn mình giống như kiểu một người
thành phố mà người ở quê giờ nhăn nhó
Mình thực ra từng có nghĩ về đấy ở vì
mình đừng hẹn hò với cũng có bạn kiểu
như thế ra mình đã từng không biết là
bạn thì bạn làm như thế nào về câu hỏi
này hơi mở tí những lại ý mình thì ạ kém
hoàn cảnh vào đây ông chị cảm chị một
người mà kiểu khá tài vật chất chẳng hạn
và tiếp xúc rất nhiều cái hiểu ở trên
thành phố các thứ thứ
không thấy việc tiếp xúc ở đây không
phải tiếp xúc về à
khi bé lắm chị ạ nó văn minh à không
phải dân chủ văn minh dùng thử hiện đại
hơn hay các thứ không phải mà ý mình
tiếp xúc với đây lại cái văn hóa ấy ra
sự giống như là bây giờ và đối với mình
trên này là kiểu
18 tuổi là có thể yêu đương mà chị Bây
giờ bọn nó đăng abc.xyz nhưng mười mấy
tuổi vậy 26 tuổi vẫn lên ABC Cái rét rồi
lại con ở quê họ sẽ được tế nhị hơn mấy
vấn đề ý em ạ Chị lấy làm một cái về văn
hóa em có rất nhiều cả về văn hóa nó có
thể xác một tí nhưng mà ngoài cái đấy ra
ý định nghĩa không ảnh hưởng gì lắm
cô sinh viên vừa làm lập trình vừa học
được không
ý tưởng được em Thực ra thì cái này mới
ở nên khuyến khích này các bạn không nên
kiểu chỉ học thôi mới các bạn phải vừa
học vừa làm và biển này không nhận tin
này ngành khác thì mình không rõ những
ngành công nghiệp in này các bạn thực
hành rất nhiều thì các bạn mới cảm thể
có hứng
em có hứng này có kinh nghiệm
cho các thứ được à
cô bạn kia đang hỏi xem là cái nào nhiều
công ty sử dụng cho các bạn nhảy sang
cái mặt câu câu này rồi nên chọn ngành
nào cũng chưa có sinh viên mình cũng hỏi
thế cậu muốn theo ngành Công nghệ thông
tin này và muốn theo cánh nghề này bởi
vì à cảm thấy nghề này đang được nhiều
nơi tuyệt nếu các bạn cứ đi theo cái xu
hướng như thế thì đầy người đang đi Còn
như thế và bình người đang vẫn Nhã để
thực sự Các bạn chọn ngành mà mà nhiều
người chọn chứ không phải là cái này phù
hợp với các bạn
các bạn đầu tiên phải tìm ngoại hiểu qua
ngày công nghệ đêm thứ nhất có rất nhiều
và nghề nó rất nhiều liên quan thì nó có
rất nhiều nghề và Mỗi nghề lại phải có
một cái tính cách phù hợp với cái nghề
đấy Thật sự giống như nghề bên lập trình
này chị các bạn không cần phải thông
minh không cần phải thông minh không cần
phải giỏi toán không cần ạ ạ thì toàn
nhiều như các bạn phải có tìm mỉ các bạn
nghĩ nhiều trường hợp tính toán các bạn
Ừ cái này nó bớt khô khan một tí so với
cái bên à kỹ thuật sâu hơn nữa nhưng mà
Ừ nhưng mà nó với các bạn nó vẫn là
những dòng cốt các bạn quen vấn đề để
được không các bạn quen nghiên cứu được
một thứ không các bạn quen đọc được tài
liệu không các bạn gặp vấn đề các bạn có
bị nặng không nếu mà các bạn nó dễ là nó
bạn không phù hợp với ngành công nghệ
tin này cái kiểu như thế còn nếu mà các
bạn thích làm việc với con người nhiều
hơn làm việc với máy tính thì các bạn sẽ
phải chọn ngày nào đấy trở thế không nên
là nghề lập trình này ngài lập trình thì
các bạn phải ngồi máy tính được nhiều
đấy các bạn phải
đừng còn theo với việc là công ty nào
đang tuyển nhiều với Vân Chính vì công
các bạn thậm chí là lời giả sự Cũng đúng
một công ty tiền đúng với nghề đấy mà
giờ sự các bạn làm để làm được nghề đấy
thì các bạn lương sẽ cao hơn cả rất
nhiều công ty đang tuyển
thi công rửa thật như thế ví dụ điển
hình về mình biết công ty đang tuyển một
ông Á tăng tiền về suy + hạ chẳng ai đưa
học sinh công cộng cả chính là chẳng ai
học chuyên xã hội Ca sĩ + thả thế là mức
lương để chuyển cái người làm vệ sinh
công cộng và mức lương đến 5.000 đâu vẫn
chưa Tuyển đủ ông nào nhưng mà chẳng ông
nào nhảy vào thì rõ ràng của ông vào học
đâu Tại mấy ông phải phân biệt không nên
chọn cái cái nghề mà nhiều công ty cùng
tuyển à
Anh Không Quan Tâm bị lừa đấy
ở cây cái khái niệm về việc là ông Ông
giỏi Ông giỏi ông không lo chết đói thì
cái đấy Hiền điên đấy nhá mình không nói
việc giỏi không mà mình nói là cách để
mà chọn cái nghề phù hợp với ông ấy là
phải ông ấy đọc qua tất cả các nghề
không Xem nghề nào hợp với tính cách của
ông nhất ông thích làm việc với con
người làm việc cái máy tính nó nghiên
cứu vớt tài liệu không Ông đọc được
tiếng Anh nó không hay các thứ thứ mình
vẫn Vân đúng ạ ạ
ở bên này công nghệ thông tin có rất
nhiều luôn từ cả bên cả phân tích tài
chính kiểu Phân tích các phương thức
cũng có thể được ngoan không em đi đông
ạ Đấy Thế nên là
về thời đại công nghệ pin rồi mà Thế nên
là mấy ông phải chọn nghệ phụ thôi đừng
có hỏi về mấy cái kiểu lại nên học ngôn
ngữ nào Vân nữa
bài hát mấy ông còn hỏi về cái muộn nữa
cũng tương tự thế không bao giờ là muộn
đâu
khi sex
khi mình tự học con và cấp chứng chỉ À
không mình Mình còn chẳng họ con Cả Sự
thật là như thế
từ hôm nay mình chưa Hôm nay anh chưa
trả lời câu hỏi liệu
em vừa ngại xã hội vừa ngại giao tiếp
vừa cốt gà cốc ga thì các bạn nếu mà các
bạn lại con gà nó có thể liên quan đến
kéo việc các bạn không thể mỉ các bạn ạ
nhưng mà các bạn có thể chuyển qua phần
bên nghiên cứu được
nghiên cứu và phân tích cũng được
Ê thằng trung vào các bạn với cái việc
bề mặt phù hợp với thì nó còn liên quan
cả sở thích sở thích theo kiểu Lại Tôi
tôi tôi thích làm được tính viên Bởi vì
tôi bảo tôi thường này việc khó chịu
những cái thứ mà tôi làm được tự động ấy
chia sẻ được nhiều cái thứ hay ho tôi
khám phá nhiều thứ hay ho hợp việc của
tôi vui khi mà xử lý được thì bất ngờ đó
mới và vẫn có khá nhiều niềm vui khi mà
khi mà làm được trình viên mà tôi thích
khi còn đương nhiên là những ngành nghề
khác thì nó sẽ có những niềm vui khác là
những cái khó chịu khác Nếu đọc qua mà
ông ấy ông ấy phù hợp với ngành những
cái niềm vui đấy mấy ông làm ông ạ
em hết quá này có người yêu không ạ Cái
này do ông quyết định về cho tôi đâu đưa
tôi phát Vì Yêu cho mà ông không hiểu
được người ta ông có quai đeo chắc tôi
không Mà người yêu và người ấy có quay
ra trách tôi không ạ
e
h Anh giới thiệu Ok anh Good For You
à à
đã hơn hai tiếng ơi mấy ông còn thắc mắc
gì không
à à
Em rất thích code Nhưng tư duy cốc không
tốt cho người khác thì làm nào để tự tin
để diễn tả là làm nhiều thôi Làm nhiều
tham khảo cốt người khác nhiều để cách
để bảo chúng ta nâng trình độ bản thân
lên cái đầu tiên các bạn các bạn phải
hình dung quyền các bạn đừng có tự ti
nữa Khi mà các bạn đầu tiên các bạn ạ
đây Tôi cho ông xem cái này
anh
em trai ai mất đủ
ai biết hết á
ở đây
em có cái ảnh này
em
đừng tự ti mà mình trúng đầu tiên là mới
nghĩa tôi không làm được này tôi không
thể làm được Tôi muốn là tôi làm như thế
nào tôi sẽ sử làng tôi làm với tôi có
thể làm được tôi sẽ làm nó và tôi làm
được thì ra là cái ngay đầu tiên cảnh
như thế này nó xác định việc đó là mình
đã muốn thay đổi rồi các bạn tự ti đúng
không Các bạn thấy là hiện tại mình đang
không ôm được chọn các bạn cần phải thay
đổi đó là bước đầu tiên rồi đó là bước
đầu tiên thì ra là đây vẫn thiếu cái
bước đấy
các bạn phải biết được đầu tiên đã các
bạn em đang có vấn đề các bạn hơn ở địa
hơn nhiều người điểm nhiều người không
nhìn ra được là họ đang có vấn đề nhưng
họ không phải thay đổi rất nhiều người
như thế Tôi thấy rất nhiều người như thế
luôn
vì họ không muốn thay đổi họ Ngại hay
đổi học bit còn không biết họ xài đấy là
cái tệ nhất
Em đợi chị ạ Thế nên là mấy ông phải
Ê mày ông đầu tiên mà ông đã biết được
mình có vấn đề rồi mình có mình học kém
mình hiểu mình Vân Vân nhìn ra được vấn
đề mình đẩy ở Thành Công một sau đó thì
mới ông sẽ
Ê mấy ông có thể nhảy cắp luôn cái đoạn
là mình làm nó bằng cách nào mình muốn
làm nó
Em đừng có bi quan như hai cái đâu Đã
ngoạn mình muốn là nó mình là nó bằng
cách nào đó sau đó thì đương nhiên là
mình sẽ thử lại đấy đã mình sẽ thử lại
Ừ thôi cũng mấy cái đoạn dưới này tôi
không biết bởi vì có ông có thể đoạn thử
làm và thất bại song ông nạn luôn thì ok
đấy à đấy em một lời ông dễ nản hay là
định cái đấy thì ta không nên lại không
biết được cái này nó ruộng mọi trường
hợp nhé Không phải mỗi lập trình không
phải mỗi học tập ấy
nhưng ít ra là mày ông phải như thế đã
nhiều ông Đoàn kiểu rừng bằng cái đoạn
này tôi không mở muốn thay đổi hoặc là
kiểu giống như mấy ông đang hỏi bảo là
tôi muốn hết rồi nhưng mà tôi cũng tôi
chỉ dừng lại đấy thôi thì sẽ 01
anh làm là mốt làm nốt mấy câu sao mày
có sao cứ để từ từ những buổi sau chứ
bây dậy hết thì hết thứ dễ mà đã bị có
tài đánh thức đã
em chỉ cách bắt chuyện với người lạ kiểu
tự tin nói chuyện với mọi người thực ra
thì tôi không khuyên mày ông ngoài việc
là về cái quan điểm nhá quan điểm là tôi
không khuyên mày ông Tất cả mọi người
đều phải trình tốt tất cả mọi người đều
nên nói chuyện cũng Chân Chung mệt mạnh
mượt về thực ra nhiều người bị áp cảm
được đấy giờ xử việc tôi nói chuyện như
này đã từng nhiều người nói tôi là mày
nói chuyện như thằng đa cấp thực hiện nó
Tao không tin mày
như thế có người bị thế ạ thế thế nên À
tôi không kiên tất cả mọi ơi cùng phải
hiểu nói chuyện rất là chua chơi thì ra
cách cái nói chuyện ổn nhất đi Tôi thấy
người ta luôn khuyên đó là
ở đó là mấy ông phải lắng nghe tốt cái
này chợ nổi
anh em không cần mấy ông mà nói chuyện
rồi nói chuyện nhạc luôn vân cũng không
cần phải nói chuyện đâu Nếu nhẹ lắng
nghe tốt lắng nghe hiện nữa người khác
thích nói và người ta sẽ thân về ông
nhanh hơn việc ông nói nhiều bắt người
ta phải nghe tôi là con người không làm
được điều đấy tôi làm nghe kèm thích nói
tôi bất người khác Hãy nghe tôi nghe tôi
phải nói chuyện hay về giờ mới nghe bạn
Còn nếu có được sự nếu mà mấy ông bạn
nói chuyện kém Romeo còn cố nói chuyện
làm gì mẹ cô lắng nghe cô đã nghe tốt và
Khoa Học cách lắng nghe có một cái nhá
ông không phải cứ thế Mùi cội im lặng từ
đầu đến cuối đâu mà ông sẽ kìa sẽ có ti
câu cảm thán thật lòng hóa để các thứ
thứ lắng nghe tốt
à Còn nếu mà thực sự ông muốn kiểu muốn
con người ông thành một con người kéo
dãn nói chuyện tốt giờ sửa ông về sau
muốn đi dậy mong muốn cái trình vân vân
ông muốn được như những cái người nói
chuyện tốt ông phải thiểu ở ông muốn
được như những người ở chợ tốt cho khỏe
ông Nguyễn Thành Tâm điểm hay là ông
muốn thành người mà được nhiều người yêu
quý người được nhiều người yêu quý là
người lắng nghe tốt cho lại nói chuyện
tốt đâu nhé người nhiều người tin tưởng
là người lắng nghe tốt phân biệt cái
điều này nhá Còn nếu mà xin số ông Chỉnh
ông muốn là làm cái nghề mà nói chuyện
hay hai câu thơ thứ muốn anh milocker
hay muốn thành nhà gì đó đúng không ạ
thì thì ông hãy xem người ấy đừng có xem
người ta nói về thành công người ta mà
hãy xem người ta đã đã chia sẻ với những
thất bại người ta mà người ta đã cách
giải quyết được là gì đấy
khi kết hợp với việc là
xem nhưng mà với con điểm là mình học
hỏi cái học hỏi cái cách nói chuyện thôi
không cần phải học hỏi tư tưởng giống
như nhớ lúc tôi nói với ông ở đây này tư
tưởng tôi không biết đúng hay sai rồi đó
là cả quan điểm cá nhân của tôi không ạ
tôi tôi cũng chỉ mới hai mấy tuổi đầu
đúng ạ Nếu là năm 30 tuổi Thật ra tôi
toàn bảo tôi luôn Chạy bớt trẻ trâu hơn
5 phút trước Tôi có câu châm ngôn này
như thế nhà em chỉ là tôi luôn trưởng
thành hơn so với năm phút trước của tôi
ở bây giờ mà chỉ cần ngày ngày mai tôi
sẽ xem lại loạn chim mày và cảm thấy
kiểu mình sẽ trâu vãi mình nói những câu
một kiểu không đi nghe lại như thế Mong
méo vẫn đang nghe
đây ạ
đề thi Ừ thì mày ông sẽ phải
anh không Không hẳn là cái gì Tao nói ra
cũng biến thành một cái một cái gì đó
đúng đừng có nghĩ là tôi nói văn vợ cho
chạy như thế Em chỉ tôi ta nói những cái
điều đúng không ạ Nếu không sẽ nghĩ lại
mà thực ra đôi khi chẳng cần nghĩ rồi
cái gì nghe được nghe không nghe được gì
được
học cái khác
ừ ừ
anh em quyết định làm thì chắc chắn phải
làm được thôi ca quan điểm đấy cũng đúng
Nhưng mà đừng có nghĩ việc là cái gì
trước Sáng làm được thì em mới làm nha
quan điểm đấy nó say vui vì ạ Có nhiều
cái mình chưa chắc chắn được mình làm
được hay không Mình sẽ hiểu sẽ mông lung
trước kia là cả Việt Nam
ở tp mới biết cơ bản
cr-v Thì ý bạn ở làm được Cái trang web
lập trình cơ bản như thế này đúng ngoại
thì có xin được đi thực tập được không
được làm đầy đủ tính năng thêm sữa xóa
xong đi được tập ở bây giờ là ổn rồi mà
18 sẽ đào tạo thêm rồi các bạn hoàn
thiện chí người ta đã tạo loại như các
bạn nhưng mà
Ừ nhưng mà thực ra thì đó các bạn nếu mà
các bạn hợp pp nhưng mình nói đấy thì
các bạn nên tự học trước cả bên về mô
hình ngồi xe opel lại cả claire có thứ
một cái Facebook đi không thì đến đấy mà
các bạn chung chờ họ đào tạo thì như
mình nói vì không phải nơi nào cũng sẽ
nào đào tạo các bạn ôi và khiến các luận
bỏ nạn bỏ dẫn nhiều khi mà nó ném ôm tài
liệu ông bị nạn đấy ông nghĩa ngày ngày
toàn khô khan ngày giờ ngồi đọc tài liệu
tư ngày qua ngày không ai giúp đỡ mình
sẽ bị điều bế tắt không ạ
các file có còn hot trong tương lai
không file của các bạn cho các fan thì
nó luôn phải có cái này là cái này không
phải hót hay không nữa nó luôn Có mà
Ừ nhưng mà Đúng là fan bây giờ nó đang
đòi hỏi thêm nhiều cả nữa thôi là phải
xử lý cảm biến cho nên nó không chỉ đơn
giản mình làm mỗi giao diện nữa
à à
thế hả Ok chứ không phải đâu ok
mvc và OB mô hình mvc
A Gọi và Ot là Hương Lập trình hướng đối
tượng
từ hạt tôi không đọc sách thì mấy đâu
nhé Tối trước hồi trước là tôi có tham
gia mới kể
mình tôi có tham gia nhiều diễn đàn mà
đọc truyện Người ta có cái chuyện à
em có dạy cách tán gái đấy
Mày có thể đọc mấy cái đấy à
Ừ
đúng rồi các bạn chỉ học qua toàn bộ cơ
bản chưa kể lại làm làm lượng gì đó à
hiển thị lên nằm đầy đủ tính năng của
một cái sản phẩm đó các bạn đi thực tập
được rồi
Không mình mình không chơi được Để chứng
khoán này là cụ chứng khoán cổ phiếu Vậy
là
Bitcoin lại tí nào gì đó nhất là gì
Vì mình chưa nghĩ đến cái đấy là thứ hai
nó bị Tính toán quá mình rất lại mấy cái
kiểu tính toán cơ thế
à à
Ừ ok Bây giờ thì hết cái tâm sự các bạn
cha muốn hỏi thêm các bạn hãy inbox
riêng hoặc cả bình luận để mình sẽ chờ
sau nhé Bố mày là hai tiếng giải khách
hôm nay tạm kết thúc gần đây nhá Chào
bạn nhé
ừ ừ